- ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ Understanding Quantum Information and Computation
ผมชื่อ John Watrous และผมเป็น Technical Director for
Education ที่ IBM Quantum
นี่คือบทเรียนที่เจ็ดของซีรีส์ และในบทเรียนนี้เราจะพูดถึงปัญหา phase estimation และวิธีแก้มัน
ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
จากนั้นเราจะนำ phase estimation ไปใช้กับปัญหาการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม ซึ่งเราได้พูดถึงในบทเรียนที่แล้ว
สิ่งที่เราจะได้คืออัลกอริทึมของ Shor ซึ่งทำให้สามารถแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
ด้วยต้นทุนพหุนามหรือในเวลาพหุนามถ้าเราชอบที่จะ
คิดในแง่ของเวลาที่ต้องใช้มากกว่าจำนวน
การดำเนินการพื้นฐานที่เราต้องการ
นี่คือเพชรเม็ดงามของ
อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมในแง่หนึ่ง และแม้ว่าการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มขนาดใหญ่
อาจมีประโยชน์จำกัดสำหรับคนส่วนใหญ่ แต่มันยังคงเป็นหนึ่งในหลักฐานที่น่าเชื่อถือที่สุด
ที่เรามีสำหรับสมมติฐานที่ว่าคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมจะ
ให้ข้อได้เปรียบที่โดดเด่น
เหนือคอมพิวเตอร์แบบคลาสสิก นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน
เราจะเริ่มด้วยนิยามของปัญหา phase estimation เอง จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงวิธีการแก้ปัญหานี้
ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
เราจะค่อยๆ ทำทีละขั้น เริ่มจากสิ่งที่คุณอาจมองว่า
เป็นการวอร์มอัพ
ในปัญหา phase estimation เป้าหมายคือการประมาณค่า
จำนวนจริงหนึ่งตัว และในส่วนวอร์มอัพนี้
เราจะดูว่าเราจะ
ได้การประมาณค่าความแม่นยำต่ำมาก
ของจำนวนนี้ได้อย่างไร
นี่จะยังไม่ดีพอ
สำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบ เมื่อเรานำคำตอบของ
ปัญหา phase estimation ไปใช้กับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
เราจะต้องใช้การประมาณค่าที่มีความแม่นยำค่อนข้างสูง แต่มันก็ยังมีประโยชน์ที่จะเริ่มด้วยการวอร์มอัพแบบนี้
เพื่อให้เข้าใจว่า
ทั้งหมดมันทำงานยังไง
จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงเรื่องการเพิ่มความแม่นยำ และนี่จะนำไปสู่
การดำเนินการที่เรียกว่า Quantum Fourier transform อย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ
เราจะดูว่าการดำเนินการนี้คืออะไรกันแน่ และมันสามารถทำได้
ด้วย quantum circuit ยังไง
และเมื่อเรามีมันแล้ว เราจะสามารถนำมันไปใช้
กับ phase estimation เพื่อสร้างขั้นตอนทั่วไปสำหรับการแก้ปัญหา
ด้วยความแม่นยำสูงมาก
จากนั้นในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะดูว่าคำตอบของ
ปัญหา phase estimation ช่วยให้เราแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพยังไง
และโดยเฉพาะสิ่งที่เราจะได้คืออัลกอริทึมของ Shor สำหรับ
การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม หรืออย่างน้อยก็สิ่งที่เทียบเท่ากับอัลกอริทึมของ Shor
วิธีที่มันทำงานคือเราให้
ก้าวกลาง ซึ่งเป็นปัญหาอีกอย่างที่เรียกว่าปัญหาการหาอันดับ
และโดยเฉพาะเราจะดูว่าเราสามารถแก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับโดยใช้ขั้นตอน phase estimation ได้ยังไง จากนั้นเราจะดูว่าเรา
สามารถแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มได้ยังไง
โดยการแก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับ เราจะเริ่มด้วยกรณีพิเศษของทฤษฎีบทที่เรียกว่า Spectral theorem
และโดยเฉพาะเราจะโฟกัสที่สิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทบอก
เราสำหรับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
Spectral theorem เป็น
ทฤษฎีบทที่สำคัญมากจากพีชคณิตเชิงเส้นและ
การวิเคราะห์เชิงฟังก์ชัน
มันบอกเราเรื่องน่าสนใจเกี่ยวกับวิธีที่การส่งเชิงเส้นบางอย่างสามารถเขียนในรูปแบบหนึ่งได้ มันมักเรียกว่า
spectral decomposition
ซึ่งมีประโยชน์ด้วยเหตุผลหลายอย่าง
และอย่างที่บอก เราจะโฟกัสที่สิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทนี้บอก
เราสำหรับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
Spectral theorem นั้น
กว้างกว่านี้ มันไม่ได้ใช้ได้กับทุกเมทริกซ์ แต่มันใช้ได้กับเมทริกซ์กลุ่มหนึ่ง
ที่เรียกว่าเมทริกซ์ปกติ ซึ่งรวมถึงเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีทั้งหมดรวมถึงเมทริกซ์บางตัว
ที่ไม่ใช่ยูนิทารี
แต่เพื่อให้เรื่องง่าย เราจะจำกัดความสนใจ
ไว้ที่เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีตอนนี้ เพราะนั่นคือทั้งหมดที่เราต้องการสำหรับ
จุดประสงค์ของบทเรียนนี้
นี่คือข้อความของ spectral theorem เฉพาะสำหรับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
สมมติว่า U เป็นเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
ขนาด N คูณ N
สิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทบอกคือ
ต้องมีฐานเชิงตั้งฉากปกติของ
เวกเตอร์ psi หนึ่งถึง psi N
พร้อมกับจำนวนเชิงซ้อน N ตัว
Lambda หนึ่งถึง Lambda N ทั้งหมดอยู่บนวงกลมหน่วยเชิงซ้อน เพื่อให้ U สามารถเขียนได้
ตามที่เราเห็นในสมการนี้
นี่เรียกว่า spectral
decomposition ของ U อย่างที่เอ่ยไปแล้ว และมันสะดวกมากที่จะรู้ว่า U สามารถเขียนในรูปแบบนี้
บางทีมันก็สะดวกที่จะมีเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้และจำนวนเหล่านี้เมื่อเราทำงานกับ
เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี U ตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง และมันก็สามารถมีประโยชน์มาก
แค่จากการรู้
ว่านิพจน์แบบนี้เป็นไปได้เสมอ เป็นวิธีหนึ่งในการพิสูจน์เรื่องบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีเป็นต้น
ในข้อความของทฤษฎีบทนี้ แต่ละจำนวน
Lambda หนึ่งถึง Lambda N ถูกเขียนในรูปแบบเฉพาะ
เป็น E ยกกำลัง สอง pi I คูณ theta โดยที่แต่ละ theta
theta หนึ่งถึง theta N เป็นจำนวนจริง และ
เราจะกลับมาที่วิธีนี้
ในการเขียนแต่ละจำนวน
เหล่านี้ในอีกสักครู่
สิ่งสำคัญที่ต้องสังเกต
เกี่ยวกับเวกเตอร์และจำนวนเหล่านี้คือ เวกเตอร์ psi
K แต่ละตัวต้องเป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของเมทริกซ์ U ที่มี
ค่าเฉพาะ Lambda K ที่สอดคล้องกัน
ซึ่งหมายความว่าถ้าเรา
คูณ psi K ด้วย U สิ่งที่เราได้คือ Lambda K คูณ psi K
ดังนั้นสิ่งที่ U ทำกับเวกเตอร์แต่ละตัวเหล่านี้คือแค่คูณมันด้วยจำนวน Lambda K ที่สอดคล้องกัน
โดยทั่วไปสำหรับเวกเตอร์ใดๆ นี่จะไม่ใช่วิธีที่ U ทำงาน แต่เวกเตอร์เฉพาะนั้นพิเศษ
และสิ่งที่ทฤษฎีบทบอกเราคือ จริงๆ แล้วมี
ฐานเชิงตั้งฉากปกติของเวกเตอร์เฉพาะเหล่านี้
สมการข้างล่างนี้ ที่จริงแล้วได้มาจากนิพจน์ที่เรามีสำหรับ U จากทฤษฎีบท ร่วมกับข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า
เวกเตอร์เป็นเชิงตั้งฉากปกติ
ถ้าเราคูณนิพจน์ของ
U กับ psi K ใดๆ และใช้ความเป็นเชิงตั้งฉากปกติของเวกเตอร์ เราจะได้ผลรวมที่
พจน์ทั้งหมดเป็นศูนย์
ยกเว้นพจน์เดียว และพจน์เดียวที่
เหลือจะดูเป็นแบบนี้
ตอนนี้เราสามารถนิยามปัญหา
phase estimation ได้แล้ว
ปัญหานี้ค่อนข้างแปลก
อย่างที่เราจะเห็น
เราได้รับสองสิ่ง อย่างแรก เราได้รับคำอธิบายของ unitary quantum circuit
ที่ทำงานบน N qubit
สำหรับค่า N ที่เลือก และเมื่อเราบอกว่านี่
เป็น unitary circuit
เราแค่หมายความว่า gate
ทั้งหมดเป็น unitary ดังนั้นไม่มีการวัดใน circuit นี้
อย่างที่สอง เราได้รับสถานะ N qubit psi และนั่นคือส่วนที่แปลก
จริงๆ แล้วเรามีสถานะควอนตัม
เป็นอินพุตสำหรับปัญหานี้ และเป็นสำเนาเดียวของสถานะนี้
สำหรับปัญหาเชิงคำนวณอื่นๆ ทั้งหมดที่เราได้พูดถึงในซีรีส์นี้ อินพุตเป็นแบบคลาสสิก ไม่ว่าจะเป็นในรูปแบบสตริง
ของบิตหรือเป็นกล่องดำ
และนั่นไม่น่าแปลกใจเพราะปัญหาเชิงคำนวณ
ที่เราพบในชีวิตประจำวันมักเป็นแบบคลาสสิก
เพราะนั่นคือปัญหาที่
เราสนใจมากที่สุด
วิธีที่เราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
ปัญหานี้คือ มันเป็นสิ่งที่ปรากฏหรือมีแนวโน้มจะปรากฏเป็นปัญหาย่อย
และขั้นตอน phase estimation ที่เราจะสร้างขึ้นมาในที่สุดคือสิ่งที่เรา
มักใช้เป็นซับรูทีน
ภายในการคำนวณที่ใหญ่กว่า สันนิษฐานว่าสำหรับปัญหา
คลาสสิกที่เราสนใจ
ตอนนี้ นี่จะเป็นปัญหาแบบ promise problem และสถานะ psi ไม่ใช่
สถานะควอนตัมอะไรก็ได้
เราได้รับสัญญาว่า psi เป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ที่ circuit ที่ให้มาอธิบาย
และเป้าหมายคือการหาหรือ
ประมาณค่าเฉพาะที่สอดคล้องกับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi
มาระบุปัญหาให้
ชัดเจนขึ้นอีกนิด
อินพุตประกอบด้วย unitary
quantum circuit บน N qubit ซึ่งสามารถเข้ารหัสเป็นสตริงของบิต
โดยใช้วิธีใดก็ตามที่เราชอบสำหรับเข้ารหัสคำอธิบาย quantum circuit พร้อมกับสถานะ N qubit psi
เราจะเรียก circuit ว่าอะไรก็ได้ แต่สิ่งที่สำคัญจริงๆ ในแง่ของข้อความของปัญหานี้คือการดำเนินการยูนิทารีเอง
ที่ถูกทำเมื่อรัน circuit และการดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีนั้นอธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ U
แต่เราไม่ได้รับ U เป็นเมทริกซ์ เราแค่ได้รับคำอธิบายของ quantum circuit ที่ implement U
สัญญาตามที่บอกไปแล้วคือ psi เป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของ U
ดังนั้นถ้าเรารัน circuit กับ psi เราจะได้ psi ออกมาคูณด้วยค่าเฉพาะ
ซึ่งจะเป็น global
phase ในสถานการณ์นั้น
และสุดท้าย เอาต์พุตของปัญหาคือการประมาณค่าเฉพาะที่สอดคล้องกับ psi และโดยเฉพาะเรากำลังมองหา
การประมาณจำนวนจริง theta ระหว่างศูนย์ถึงหนึ่ง รวม
ศูนย์ แต่ไม่รวมหนึ่ง
ที่ทำให้สมการที่เรา
มีบนหน้าจอเป็นจริง
เพื่ออธิบายวิธีนี้ในการ
กำหนดพารามิเตอร์ค่าเฉพาะที่สอดคล้องกับ psi และเพื่อชี้แจงว่าเราหมายถึงอะไรกับการประมาณ
มาวาดรูปวงกลม
หน่วยเชิงซ้อนกัน
เราสามารถวางจำนวน หนึ่ง, I,
ลบหนึ่ง, และลบ I ในตำแหน่งปกติ และเราสามารถพิจารณา
จุดใดๆ บนวงกลม
ที่กำหนดพารามิเตอร์ด้วย theta ตามที่เรามีในข้อความของปัญหา
นี่คือจุดที่เราได้
ถ้าเราเริ่มจากหนึ่งแล้วหมุนด้วยมุม
สอง คูณ pi คูณ theta ดังนั้นมุมไม่ใช่
theta แต่เป็นสอง pi theta
และอีกวิธีคิดคือ ถ้าเราเริ่มที่หนึ่งแล้วเดินทางระยะทาง สอง pi theta บนวงกลม
เราจะไปถึงจุด E ยกกำลัง
สอง คูณ pi คูณ theta ของเรา
ทุกจุดบนวงกลมหน่วยเชิงซ้อนสามารถแสดงในแบบนี้
สำหรับค่า theta ที่ไม่ซ้ำกัน
และนั่นเป็นเพราะเราไป
รอบวงกลมพอดีเมื่อ theta ไปจากศูนย์ถึงหนึ่ง และถ้าเราไป
ถึง theta เท่ากับหนึ่ง
เราจะกลับมาที่จุดเริ่มต้น
ที่ theta เท่ากับศูนย์ ดังนั้นนั่นจึงเป็นเหตุผลที่เรารวมศูนย์ แต่ไม่รวมหนึ่ง
เพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าแต่ละจุด
บนวงกลมหน่วยเชิงซ้อนสอดคล้องกับค่า theta ที่ไม่ซ้ำกันในช่วงที่เราพิจารณา
มีหลายวิธีที่เรา
อาจจะจินตนาการการประมาณค่า theta แต่วิธีที่เราจะทำคือประมาณ theta ด้วยเศษส่วน
โดยตัวส่วนเป็น
สองยกกำลัง M สำหรับจำนวนเต็มบวก M ที่เลือก และตัวเศษเป็นจำนวนเต็ม y
ระหว่างศูนย์ถึงสองยกกำลัง M ลบหนึ่ง
เราอาจคิดว่านี่เป็นการประมาณ m บิตของ theta ถ้าต้องการ และเราสามารถเขียนจำนวนนี้
ในสัญกรณ์ฐานสอง
โดยมีจุดฐานสองตามด้วยการแสดง
ฐานสองของ Y
ผมบอกว่าจุดฐานสอง
อย่างไรก็ตาม แทนที่จะบอกว่าจุดทศนิยมเพราะทศนิยมหมายถึงฐาน 10 และผมกำลังพูดถึง
ฐานสองที่นี่ แต่เป็นแนวคิดเดียวกัน
แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม เราสามารถ
คิดว่ามันเป็นเศษส่วนอย่างที่ปรากฏบนหน้าจอ
และเพื่อความชัดเจน เมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
การประมาณในบริบทนี้ ควรเข้าใจ
ว่าค่าของ theta
ใกล้ศูนย์และค่าของ theta ใกล้หนึ่งนั้นจริงๆ แล้วอยู่ใกล้กัน
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า theta เท่ากับ 0.99 และเราประมาณค่า
theta นี้ด้วยค่าศูนย์
นั่นก็เป็นการประมาณที่ดีพอสมควร ในแง่ที่ว่ามันอยู่
ภายในหนึ่งในร้อยของค่าจริง เมื่อ
เราวนรอบวงกลม
แล้วกลับไปที่ศูนย์เมื่อเราถึงหนึ่ง
คำว่า modular one บางครั้งใช้เพื่ออธิบายสถานการณ์ ที่เรา
ถือว่า theta เท่ากับหนึ่งกับ theta เท่ากับศูนย์เป็นสิ่งเดียวกัน
ประเด็นคือเราสนใจตำแหน่งของจุด
E ยกกำลัง สอง pi I theta บนวงกลมหน่วยจริงๆ
และการคิดเกี่ยวกับ
วิธีการประมาณ theta แบบนี้ก็สมเหตุสมผลเมื่อเรามีเป้าหมายนั้นในใจ
ข้อความของปัญหาเอง
ตามที่ปรากฏบนหน้าจอ ไม่ได้ระบุว่าการประมาณ theta ต้องดีแค่ไหน
แต่นั่นเป็นสิ่งที่เราสามารถปรับแต่งได้ตามความต้องการ
ในบางสถานการณ์เราอาจพอใจกับการประมาณ
theta ที่มีความแม่นยำต่ำ และในสถานการณ์อื่นเราอาจต้องการ
การประมาณที่มีความแม่นยำสูงมาก และข้อความของปัญหาเอง
สามารถปรับปรุงให้เหมาะสม
ต่อไปเราจะดูว่าเราสามารถแก้
ปัญหา phase estimation ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้ยังไง และ
เราจะเริ่มด้วยการวอร์มอัพ
นี่จะยังไม่ใช่คำตอบ
สุดท้ายของปัญหา
สิ่งที่เราจะทำคือใช้ปรากฏการณ์ phase kickback เพื่อพยายามเรียนรู้บางอย่าง
เกี่ยวกับค่าเฉพาะที่สอดคล้องกับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะที่ให้มา
จำได้ว่าในปัญหา
phase estimation เราได้รับคำอธิบาย
ของ unitary quantum circuit สำหรับการดำเนินการ U บางตัว
และสิ่งที่เราทำก่อนคือ
ใช้คำอธิบาย circuit นี้เพื่อสร้าง circuit ใหม่ที่ implement การดำเนินการ controlled U อย่าง
ที่เห็นในรูปบนหน้าจอ
นี่ค่อนข้างง่าย สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือเพิ่ม control qubit ซึ่งอยู่
ด้านบนในแผนภาพนี้
และใช้ control qubit
ใหม่นี้เป็นตัวควบคุมสำหรับทุก gate ที่
ปรากฏใน circuit ของเรา
ดังนั้น gate ทั้งหมดจะถูกนำไปใช้ถ้า control qubit นี้ตั้งค่าเป็นหนึ่ง และไม่มี gate ใดถูกใช้ถ้า control qubit ตั้งค่าเป็นศูนย์
นั่นหมายความว่าเราจะ
ต้องมีเวอร์ชัน controlled ของทุก gate ที่
ปรากฏใน circuit U แต่เราไม่ต้องคิด
เกี่ยวกับ controlled gate ใหม่เหล่านี้
ว่าเป็น gate เดี่ยวถ้าเราไม่ต้องการ มันอาจ implement
เป็น circuit เล็กๆ ที่ทำจาก gate ต่างๆ จากชุด gate ใดก็ตาม
ที่เราเลือกใช้ และเมื่อเรามี
เวอร์ชัน controlled ของ U เราสามารถพิจารณาการรัน circuit นี้
ที่เราทำให้ control qubit อยู่ในสถานะ superposition ของศูนย์กับหนึ่งก่อน ใช้ controlled U gate กับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi ที่ได้รับมา
จากนั้นใช้ Hadamard gate
กับ control แล้ววัด
เราจะเห็นว่าทำไมมันถึงสมเหตุสมผลเมื่อเราวิเคราะห์ แต่ก่อนที่จะลงรายละเอียด เราเห็นความคล้ายคลึง
กับอัลกอริทึมของ Deutsche เป็นต้น ที่เราใช้
Hadamard gate สองตัวแล้ววัดเพื่อ
ตรวจสอบ
ว่าการดำเนินการที่ให้มา
กำลังทำอะไรอยู่
มันเป็น controlled unitary
แทนที่จะเป็น query gate แต่มีแนวคิดที่คล้ายกันมากอยู่เบื้องหลัง
มาดูกันว่า circuit ทำอะไร
สถานะเริ่มต้นคือเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi tensor กับสถานะ
ศูนย์สำหรับ control qubit
การใช้ Hadamard gate แรกจะแปลงสถานะของ
qubit บนเป็นสถานะ plus และเราสามารถขยาย
สถานะทั้งหมดตามที่แสดงตรงนี้
จากนั้นเราใช้การดำเนินการ controlled U และสิ่งที่มันทำคือใช้ U กับ psi เมื่อ control qubit ตั้งค่าเป็นหนึ่ง
แต่ไม่ใช่เมื่อตั้งค่าเป็นศูนย์ เราจึงได้สถานะ pi สอง
ที่เขียนไว้บนหน้าจอ
เราสามารถทำให้สถานะง่ายขึ้น
โดยใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า psi เป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของ U ที่มีค่าเฉพาะ e ยกกำลัง สอง pi I theta
เราจึงได้ค่าเฉพาะนั้นคูณกับพจน์ที่สอง
แต่ไม่ใช่พจน์แรก
และเราสามารถทำให้ง่ายขึ้นโดยใช้ bilinearity
ของ tensor product
ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เรามีนี้คือ
ปรากฏการณ์ phase kickback แต่คราวนี้มันเกิดขึ้นกับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi ใดๆ ของการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ใดๆ
แทนที่จะเป็นการดำเนินการ not ที่ใช้กับสถานะ
minus โดยเฉพาะ
นั่นคือสถานะหลังจากใช้การดำเนินการ controlled U แล้ว
ยังไงก็ตาม ควรใช้เวลา
สังเกตว่าสถานะของ N qubit ด้านล่างยังคงเป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi
ซึ่งดีมากเพราะมัน
ให้โอกาสเราใช้มันอีกครั้งถ้าเราต้องการ
จากนั้น Hadamard gate ตัวที่สองถูกทำ และนี่คือสถานะที่เราได้
และผมไม่ได้แสดงรายละเอียด
ทั้งหมดของการหา แต่ถ้าเราใช้
Hadamard gate แล้วทำให้ง่ายขึ้น นี่คือสิ่งที่ควรได้
นั่นคือสถานะก่อน
การวัดพอดี
เราจึงโฟกัสที่สถานะนี้เพื่อดูว่าเราเรียนรู้อะไร
เกี่ยวกับ theta ได้จากการวัด
และถ้าเราวัด qubit
บนหรือ qubit ขวาสุด เหล่านี้คือความน่าจะเป็นที่เราได้สำหรับสองผลลัพธ์
และที่นี่ผมใช้สูตรพื้นฐาน
สองสามตัวที่เชื่อมโยง sin และ cosine
กับ exponential เชิงซ้อน เพื่อแสดงความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้
ในแง่ของ sin และ cosine
โดยเฉพาะ ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ศูนย์คือ cosine กำลังสองของ pi คูณ theta และความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้หนึ่ง
คือ sin กำลังสองของมุมเดียวกัน และนี่สมเหตุสมผล
เพราะ sin กำลังสองบวก cosine กำลังสองของ
มุมใดๆ เท่ากับหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นความน่าจะเป็นของเรา
รวมกันเป็นหนึ่งอย่างที่คาดหวัง
และนี่คือกราฟของความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้เป็นฟังก์ชันของ theta
เพื่อความชัดเจน นี่คือกราฟของ
ความน่าจะเป็นเอง ไม่ใช่กราฟที่แสดงการแจกแจงความน่าจะเป็น
ตัวเดียวเป็นต้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า theta
เท่ากับครึ่งหนึ่ง ความน่าจะเป็นที่
เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์หนึ่ง ซึ่งวาดเป็นสีม่วง จะเท่ากับหนึ่ง
ในขณะที่ความน่าจะเป็น
ที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ ซึ่งวาดเป็นสีน้ำเงิน จะเป็นศูนย์
ในทางกลับกัน ถ้า theta เท่ากับ
หนึ่งในสี่หรือสามในสี่ เราจะได้ว่าทั้งสองผลลัพธ์มีโอกาสเท่ากัน
และแน่นอนสำหรับทุกค่าของ theta ผลรวมของความน่าจะเป็นจะเท่ากับหนึ่งอย่างที่เราสังเกตไปแล้ว
เราจึงไม่รู้ค่า theta
อย่างแน่ชัดจากขั้นตอนนี้ แต่มันให้ข้อมูล
บางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ theta
และถ้าเราจินตนาการสถานการณ์ที่เราได้สัญญาว่า
theta เท่ากับศูนย์หรือ theta เท่ากับครึ่งหนึ่ง ขั้นตอนนี้จะบอกเรา
ได้อย่างแน่ชัดว่าเป็น
ความเป็นไปได้ตัวไหน
นั่นเป็นวิธีง่ายๆ ที่เราสามารถใช้ปรากฏการณ์ phase kickback เพื่อเรียนรู้บางอย่างเกี่ยวกับค่าเฉพาะ
แล้วเราจะเรียนรู้เพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับค่าเฉพาะได้ยังไง?
นี่เป็นสถานการณ์ที่เราสามารถให้
ความไม่รู้เป็นตัวนำทาง
เพราะจริงๆ แล้วมีไม่กี่
อย่างที่เราทำได้
เราไม่รู้อะไรมากเกี่ยวกับ
เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi และเราก็ไม่รู้
อะไรมากเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการ U
เรามี circuit สำหรับ U แต่เท่าที่เรารู้ มัน
อาจเป็นเรื่องที่น่ากลัว สับสน ที่เราไม่สามารถ
ทำความเข้าใจได้โดยการตรวจสอบมัน
แต่ทางเลือกที่เป็นธรรมชาติอย่างหนึ่งคือรัน circuit หลายครั้ง
โดยเฉพาะ เราอาจลองทำสิ่งเดียวกับที่เราเพิ่งทำ ยกเว้นว่าแทนที่จะใช้ controlled U operation เพียงครั้งเดียว
เราใช้การดำเนินการนั้นสองครั้ง หรือเราอาจใช้กี่ครั้งก็ได้ แต่มาเริ่มที่สองครั้ง
เพื่อดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
จริงๆ แล้วค่อนข้างง่าย
ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น การใช้ controlled
U operation สองครั้ง เราแค่
ยกกำลังสองค่าเฉพาะ
เพราะมันจะถูกเตะเข้าไปใน
phase ของ qubit บนสองครั้งแทนที่จะเป็นครั้งเดียว
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
ความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์เป็นฟังก์ชันของ theta เราก็แค่
เพิ่มความถี่เป็นสองเท่า
สำหรับแต่ละค่า theta ที่เป็นไปได้ ความน่าจะเป็นของผลลัพธ์
จะเหมือนกับที่จะเป็นถ้าเราเพิ่ม theta เป็นสองเท่าแล้ว
เอาส่วนทศนิยม
เพื่อให้ได้จำนวนระหว่างศูนย์กับหนึ่ง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า theta
เท่ากับครึ่งหนึ่ง ค่าเฉพาะก็จะเป็นลบหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นการใช้ U สองครั้ง เราจะยกกำลังสองค่าเฉพาะและผลลัพธ์จะเหมือนกับ theta เท่ากับศูนย์
ซึ่งก็คือความน่าจะเป็น
สำหรับผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ ที่แสดงเป็นสีน้ำเงิน จะเท่ากับหนึ่ง และความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับผลลัพธ์หนึ่ง ที่แสดงเป็นสีม่วง จะเท่ากับศูนย์
นี่ง่ายมาก แต่เราสามารถ
ได้ข้อมูลเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับ theta โดยการทำแบบนี้จริงๆ
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรารู้ล่วงหน้าว่า theta เท่ากับศูนย์หรือ theta เท่ากับหนึ่งในสี่ circuit นี้จะเปิดเผยให้เรารู้
ว่าเป็นความเป็นไปได้ตัวไหน
ในทางกลับกัน เราไม่สามารถแยกแยะกรณีที่ theta เท่ากับศูนย์ออกจากกรณีที่ theta เท่ากับครึ่งหนึ่งได้อีกต่อไป
ดังนั้นขั้นตอนนี้ไม่ได้ดีกว่าอย่างเคร่งครัดเมื่อเทียบกับก่อนหน้า
ที่เรามี controlled U gate ตัวเดียว แต่โดยการรัน circuit นี้ด้วย
เราสามารถได้ข้อมูลเพิ่มเติม
มันยังไม่ชัดเจนนัก
ว่าข้อมูลเพิ่มเติมที่เราได้จากการทำ controlled U operation หลายครั้ง
สามารถรวมกับ
ข้อมูลที่ได้จากการทำเพียงครั้งเดียวได้ยังไง และจริงๆ แล้วมีหลาย
วิธีที่เราทำได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น มีเทคนิคที่เรียกว่า iterative phase estimation ซึ่งเกี่ยวข้องกับการรัน circuit แบบที่เราเห็น
พร้อมกับการเปลี่ยนแปลงเล็กน้อย เพื่อหาค่าประมาณของ theta
แต่ผมจะอธิบาย
วิธีที่เรียกได้ว่าเป็นแนวทางแบบดั้งเดิมกว่า ที่เราใช้ quantum circuit ตัวเดียวที่มี control qubit หลายตัว
ที่ควบคุมจำนวนรอบ
ที่แตกต่างกันของการดำเนินการยูนิทารี U
ก่อนอื่นผมจะอธิบายว่า
มันทำงานยังไงสำหรับ control qubit สองตัว จากนั้นหลังจากนั้นเราจะขยายไปยัง control qubit มากกว่าสองตัว
นี่คือ quantum circuit
ที่ใช้ control qubit สองตัว
control qubit ตัวบน
ควบคุมการดำเนินการ U ครั้งเดียว ในขณะที่ qubit ตัวที่สองจากบน
ควบคุม U สองชุด
ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราทำคือรวม circuit สองตัวที่เราเห็นก่อนหน้านี้เข้าด้วยกัน ในแบบที่ใช้สำเนาเดียว
ของเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi ที่เรามี
จะสังเกตได้ว่า
Hadamard gate หลังการดำเนินการ controlled U
ถูกลบออกแล้ว และยังไม่มีการวัด
สิ่งที่เราจะทำคือ
ดูว่า circuit นี้ทำงานยังไง จากนั้นเราจะหาว่า
ควรทำอะไรกับ qubit สองตัวบน
เพื่อเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับค่า theta ให้
มากที่สุดเท่าที่จะทำได้
หลังจากทำ Hadamard gate แล้ว เราได้สถานะที่
แสดงบนหน้าจอ
และนี่จะเป็นวิธีที่สะดวกในการเขียนสถานะเพื่อ
ดูว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นต่อไป
A ศูนย์ และ A หนึ่ง เป็นบิต และถ้าเราคิดว่า qubit สองตัวบนเป็น register สอง qubit
เราคิดว่า A ศูนย์ ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับ qubit บน เป็นบิตที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยกว่า และ A หนึ่ง ซึ่งสอดคล้อง
กับ control qubit ล่าง
เป็นบิตที่มีนัยสำคัญมากกว่า
หลังจากการดำเนินการ controlled
U ตัวแรก เราได้สถานะนี้
สถานะคลาสสิกที่สอดคล้องกับ control qubit ตัวบนคือ a ศูนย์ ดังนั้นผลลัพธ์ของ phase kickback
สามารถแสดงได้แบบนี้ จากนั้นหลังจากการดำเนินการ controlled U
ตัวที่สองและตัวที่สาม
เราได้สถานะนี้
แนวคิดเหมือนกับตัวแรก ยกเว้นว่าคราวนี้เราใช้ controlled U operation สองครั้ง
ดังนั้นเราคูณ A หนึ่ง ด้วยสอง
ในเลขชี้กำลังเพื่อสะท้อนสิ่งนี้
และตอนนี้เราสามารถทำให้นิพจน์นี้ง่ายขึ้นโดยคิดเกี่ยวกับบิต
A หนึ่ง และ A ศูนย์ รวมกันเป็นจำนวนเต็มระหว่างศูนย์
ถึงสาม โดยใช้สัญกรณ์ฐานสอง
นั่นคือเมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
สตริงสองบิต A หนึ่ง A ศูนย์ เป็นการเข้ารหัส
ฐานสองของจำนวนเต็ม
สิ่งที่เราได้คือ สอง
คูณ A หนึ่ง บวก A ศูนย์
และความเข้าใจคือ
เมื่อเราเขียน ket X เราหมายถึง X ที่เขียนเป็นสตริงฐานสองความยาว
สอง โดยใช้สัญกรณ์ฐานสอง
ตอนนี้มาโฟกัสที่
control qubit สองตัวนี้เพื่อหาว่าเราเรียนรู้
อะไรเกี่ยวกับ theta จากมันได้ ณ จุดนี้
N qubit ที่เหลือยัง
อยู่ในสถานะ psi เดิมที่ได้รับมา ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่
วิเศษมากของวิธีนี้
เพราะอย่างที่บอก เราสามารถใช้สถานะนั้นอีกครั้งถ้าต้องการได้ข้อมูล
เกี่ยวกับ theta เพิ่มเติม
แต่ตอนนี้ มาคิดว่าเราเรียนรู้อะไรได้
จาก control qubit สองตัวนี้
เพื่อช่วยเราหาวิธีดำเนินการต่อ มาจินตนาการว่าเราได้สัญญาว่า theta เท่ากับ Y หารด้วยสี่
สำหรับจำนวนเต็ม y ระหว่างศูนย์ถึงสาม
โดยทั่วไป theta อาจไม่ใช่
หนึ่งในสี่ค่านี้ แต่นี่เป็นกรณีที่เป็นธรรมชาติที่จะพิจารณา
เราเห็นในเวอร์ชันดั้งเดิมที่มี control qubit ตัวเดียวว่า ถ้าเราได้สัญญาว่า theta เท่ากับศูนย์หรือครึ่งหนึ่ง
circuit จะเปิดเผยว่าเป็นค่าไหน และเราก็สังเกตด้วยว่า ในเวอร์ชันที่เราใช้
controlled U operation สองครั้ง
เราสามารถแยกแยะกรณี theta เท่ากับศูนย์ออกจากกรณี theta
เท่ากับหนึ่งในสี่ได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ
ดังนั้นเราอาจหวังว่า circuit ใหม่ของเราจะแยกแยะสี่กรณีเหล่านี้ได้
โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว สิ่งที่
เราทำคือใช้แนวคิดของ promise problem
เพื่อทำให้ปัญหาง่ายขึ้น เพื่อที่เราจะได้เห็นวิธีดำเนินการ
และนั่นไม่ใช่ความคิดที่แย่โดยทั่วไป ถ้าเรามีปัญหาและ
ไม่รู้วิธีแก้ ลองทำให้มันง่ายขึ้น
ถ้าเราแก้ปัญหาที่ง่ายกว่าได้ ข้อมูลเชิงลึกที่ได้อาจเป็นประโยชน์ในการแก้ปัญหาทั่วไปกว่า
และถ้าเราแก้ปัญหาที่ง่ายกว่าไม่ได้ เราอาจยังไม่พร้อม
สำหรับปัญหาทั่วไปกว่า
ดังนั้นก็ทำให้มันง่ายลงเรื่อยๆ
จนกว่าจะแก้ได้
อย่างไรก็ตาม กลับมาที่ปัญหาของเรา มานิยามสถานะสอง qubit สำหรับแต่ละค่าที่เป็นไปได้ของ Y
กล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง phi Y เท่ากับสถานะ
ที่แสดงด้านบนของหน้าจอ เมื่อ theta ถูกเลือก
โดยเฉพาะให้เป็น Y หารด้วยสี่
และนี่คือสี่สถานะนั้น
เขียนออกมาชัดเจน
เพื่อย้ำอีกครั้ง ถ้า
theta เท่ากับ Y หารด้วยสี่ สำหรับ Y เป็นศูนย์ หนึ่ง สอง หรือ
สาม และเรารัน circuit
เราจะเหลือ
สถานะหนึ่งในสี่ตัวนี้ อันที่สอดคล้อง
กับค่า Y ที่ถูกต้อง
และเราแค่ต้องการหาว่า
มันเป็นตัวไหน
และคำถามคือ สิ่งนี้เป็นไปได้ไหม?
และคำตอบของคำถามนั้นคือใช่ เพราะสี่สถานะเหล่านี้เป็นเชิงตั้งฉาก
ถ้าคำนวณ inner product
ระหว่างคู่ใดๆ จะได้ศูนย์
และเพราะมันเป็นเชิงตั้งฉาก มันจึงสามารถแยกแยะได้อย่างสมบูรณ์แบบด้วยการวัดแบบ projective
และโดยเฉพาะเราสามารถ
แสดงการวัดแบบนั้นโดยนิยาม projection หนึ่งตัวสำหรับแต่ละเวกเตอร์อย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้
มันใช้ได้เสมอ เมื่อใดก็ตาม
ที่เรามีฐานเชิงตั้งฉากปกติ และเราสามารถตรวจสอบ
กับนิยามที่เราเห็นในบทเรียนที่สาม
สำหรับกรณีเฉพาะนี้
ถ้าเราต้องการ ดังนั้นเราสรุปได้ว่าเป็น
ไปได้ที่จะทำภารกิจของเรา
ซึ่งก็คือเรียนรู้ค่าของ Y จากสถานะที่แสดง
ด้านบนของหน้าจอ
และถ้าเราต้องการทำแบบนั้น
ด้วย quantum circuit เราสามารถดำเนินการตามที่ผมจะอธิบาย
ก่อนอื่นเรานิยามเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี V ที่มีคอลัมน์เป็นสี่
เวกเตอร์เรียงตามลำดับ
เมทริกซ์นั้นจะมีการกระทำตามที่อธิบายด้านล่างของหน้าจอ
กับสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
และเราสามารถเขียนเมทริกซ์ออกมา
เพื่อดูว่ามันหน้าตาเป็นยังไง
เพราะ V ส่งแต่ละสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน ket Y ไปยังเวกเตอร์ phi Y เราจึงมีว่า โดยการใช้ V dagger
หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง V ผกผัน กับ phi Y จะแปลงกลับไปทางอื่นเป็นสถานะฐานมาตรฐานที่สอดคล้องกัน
ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราทำได้คือใช้ V dagger กับสถานะใดก็ตาม
ที่ได้จาก circuit ของเรา
จากนั้นถ้าเราทำ
การวัดฐานมาตรฐาน เราจะได้ตัวเลข Y
ที่เรากำลังหา แสดงเป็นสตริง
ความยาวสองในฐานสอง
ก่อนจะไปต่อ มาพูดเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี V สักหน่อย
นี่เป็นเมทริกซ์พิเศษและ
เราอาจเคยเห็นมาก่อน
มันเป็นเมทริกซ์ที่เชื่อมโยงกับ
การดำเนินการเชิงเส้นบนเวกเตอร์สี่มิติที่เรียกว่า discrete Fourier transform
พูดให้แม่นยำกว่า discrete Fourier transform สามารถนิยามได้สำหรับ
มิติจำนวนเต็มบวกใดๆ และเราจะดูมัน
ในแบบทั่วไปในอีกสักครู่
และนี่คือหน้าตาของมัน
โดยเฉพาะเมื่อมิติเท่ากับสี่
เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
discrete Fourier transform ได้หลายแบบ
เราอาจคิดเกี่ยวกับมันอย่างเป็นนามธรรมล้วนๆ ว่าเป็นการส่งเชิงเส้นบนเวกเตอร์ที่แสดงด้วยเมทริกซ์
และเราก็สามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
มันเป็นปัญหาเชิงคำนวณ ที่เราได้รับเวกเตอร์ และเราต้องการคำนวณผลลัพธ์
ของการใช้การส่งเชิงเส้นนี้
มันกลายเป็นปัญหาเชิงคำนวณ
ที่สำคัญอย่างเหลือเชื่อ และมีอัลกอริทึมที่มีประสิทธิภาพสูงสำหรับการคำนวณนั้น
ที่เรียกว่า fast Fourier transform
จริงๆ แล้ว นี่เป็นปัญหาที่สำคัญมากในการประมวลผลสัญญาณเป็นต้น จนกระทั่ง fast Fourier
transform ถูกถือว่าโดยหลายคน
ว่าเป็นหนึ่งในอัลกอริทึมที่สำคัญและมีผลกระทบ
มากที่สุดเท่าที่เคยค้นพบ
เราก็สามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
discrete Fourier transform ว่าเป็นการดำเนินการควอนตัมยูนิทารีที่ใช้กับ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
และเมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับมันแบบนั้น เราเรียกมันว่า quantum Fourier
transform หรือ QFT อย่างย่อ
ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ มันเป็นสิ่งเดียวกันกับ discrete Fourier transform โดยพื้นฐาน แต่เราเรียกมันว่า
quantum Fourier transform
เพื่อชี้แจงว่ามันเป็นการดำเนินการที่ใช้กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
มาเปลี่ยนชื่อเมทริกซ์จาก V เป็น QFT สี่ เพื่อสะท้อนข้อเท็จจริง
ว่าการดำเนินการที่เราสร้างขึ้นคือ quantum Fourier transform
นี่คือ circuit ทั้งหมดสำหรับการเรียนรู้ค่าของ Y เมื่อเราได้สัญญาว่า
theta เท่ากับ Y หารด้วยสี่
สำหรับ Y เป็นศูนย์ หนึ่ง สอง หรือสาม
และเพื่อให้ชัดเจน เราใช้ผกผันของ
quantum Fourier transform หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง QFT สี่ dagger
เพื่อส่งหนึ่งในสี่สถานะที่เป็นไปได้กลับไปยังสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน ket Y เพื่อที่เราจะกู้คืน Y ได้โดยการวัด
นั่นคือ circuit ที่เราได้
จากการคิดเกี่ยวกับเวอร์ชัน promise ของ
ปัญหา phase estimation ที่เราได้สัญญาว่า theta
เท่ากับศูนย์ หนึ่งในสี่
ครึ่งหนึ่ง หรือสามในสี่ แต่ไม่มีอะไรที่ห้าม
เราจากการรัน circuit นี้
สำหรับค่า theta ใดก็ได้
และถ้าเราทำแบบนั้น นี่
คือความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับสี่ผลลัพธ์
ที่เป็นไปได้ที่เราได้
แต่ละค่าจากสี่ค่า
ที่เป็นไปได้ของ Y มีสีของมันเอง และกราฟบอกเรา
ว่าความน่าจะเป็นเป็นเท่าไรสำหรับแต่ละค่าเป็นฟังก์ชันของ theta
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า theta
เท่ากับสามในสี่ เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์
สามด้วยความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่ง
ในขณะที่ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับอีกสามผลลัพธ์เป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด อย่างที่เรารู้แล้วจากการคิดเกี่ยวกับเวอร์ชัน promise ของปัญหา
ถ้า theta ใกล้สามในสี่แต่ไม่ได้เท่ากับสามในสี่พอดี จะมีความน่าจะเป็นที่ไม่เป็นศูนย์สำหรับผลลัพธ์อื่นๆ
แต่เราจะยังคงได้ผลลัพธ์
สามด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสูง
ดังนั้นแม้ว่า theta อาจ
ไม่เท่ากับ Y หารด้วยสี่ เราก็ยังคิด
เกี่ยวกับผลลัพธ์ที่ได้จากการวัดหารด้วยสี่
ว่าเป็นการเดาหรือ
การประมาณของ theta ได้
การเดาอาจผิด แต่มันก็ยัง
ให้ข้อมูลแก่เรา
และสิ่งหนึ่งที่เรา
เรียนรู้จากกราฟคือ การประมาณที่ดีที่สุดจะมีความน่าจะเป็น
ที่สูงที่สุดเสมอ
เมื่อผมพูดว่าการประมาณที่ดีที่สุด ผมหมายถึงค่า Y หารด้วยสี่ ที่ใกล้กับค่า theta จริงที่สุด
ในความหมาย modular one กรณีที่แย่ที่สุดคือ theta อยู่กึ่งกลางพอดี
ระหว่างสองค่าของ Y หารด้วยสี่
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า theta เท่ากับ
สามในแปด หรือ 0.375 ในกรณีนี้เราจะเห็น
ว่าการประมาณ
หนึ่งในสี่ และ สองในสี่
หรือครึ่งหนึ่ง ดีเท่ากัน
ดังนั้นในกรณีนี้
จริงๆ แล้วมีการประมาณที่ดีที่สุดสองตัวแทนที่จะเป็นหนึ่ง
และเรามีโอกาสเท่ากันที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์หนึ่ง
กับผลลัพธ์สอง
อีกสองผลลัพธ์คือ ศูนย์ และ สาม ซึ่งไม่ได้ให้
การประมาณ theta ที่ดีมากเมื่อหารด้วยสี่ จริงๆ แล้วปรากฏด้วยความน่าจะเป็นบางอย่าง
ซึ่งดูเหมือนจะต่ำกว่า
10% เล็กน้อยในทั้งสองกรณี
ดังนั้นขั้นตอนนี้ไม่สมบูรณ์แบบ แต่มันให้ข้อมูลแก่เรา
และสิ่งที่น่าสังเกตคือ
ไม่ว่า theta จะเป็นเท่าไร เราได้รับการรับประกันว่าจะได้การประมาณที่ดีที่สุดเสมอ
หรือหนึ่งในสองการประมาณที่ดีที่สุดเมื่อเสมอกัน ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ดูเหมือนจะสูงกว่า 40% เล็กน้อย
และยิ่ง theta ใกล้กับ
การประมาณเท่าไร ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะเห็นค่า Y ที่สอดคล้องก็ยิ่งสูง
และนั่นเป็นการปรับปรุง
ที่สำคัญเมื่อเทียบกับการใช้ control qubit ตัวเดียว
นี่คือขั้นตอน phase
estimation เมื่อเราเลือกใช้ control qubit สองตัว
และสิ่งที่เราจะทำต่อไปคือขยาย
ขั้นตอนนี้อย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ ที่เราไม่หยุดแค่
control qubit สองตัว
แต่ใช้ control qubit
กี่ตัวก็ได้ที่เราเลือก
และสิ่งที่เราจะเห็นคือ โดยการ
ขยายขั้นตอน โดยการเพิ่ม control qubit มากขึ้น เราจะสามารถได้การประมาณ
theta ที่แม่นยำมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆ และนั่นจะเป็นขั้นตอน
phase estimation ทั่วไป
เพื่อขยายขั้นตอน
phase estimation จาก control qubit สองตัว
ไปยังจำนวนที่เราเลือก เราจะต้องเข้าใจ
ว่า quantum Fourier transform ถูกนิยามสำหรับมิติอื่นๆ ยังไง
และเราก็จะต้องพูดถึงว่ามันสามารถ implement
ด้วย quantum circuit ได้ยังไง
นี่คือนิยามของ quantum
Fourier transform เมื่อมิติเป็น
จำนวนเต็มบวก N ใดก็ได้
ที่นี่เราคิดเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการนี้ว่าเป็นการดำเนินการบนระบบที่มีสถานะคลาสสิกเป็น
ศูนย์ถึง N ลบหนึ่ง
และที่นี่เมทริกซ์ที่
อธิบายการดำเนินการนี้ถูกแสดงโดยใช้
สัญกรณ์ Dirac
เราก็สามารถอธิบายมันในแง่ของการกระทำ
กับสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน เพื่อเชื่อมโยงกับ
สิ่งที่เราเห็นแล้วเมื่อ N เท่ากับสี่
นี่คือหน้าตาของมัน
เมื่อ N เท่ากับหนึ่ง ซึ่งไม่ใช่กรณีที่น่าสนใจมาก
นี่คือเมื่อ N เท่ากับสอง และจะสังเกตว่าสิ่งที่เราได้ในกรณีนี้คือการดำเนินการ Hadamard
นี่คือ quantum Fourier
transform สำหรับ N เท่ากับสาม
สำหรับ N เท่ากับสี่ ที่
เราเห็นไปแล้ว
และสำหรับตัวอย่างสุดท้าย นี่คือเมื่อ N เท่ากับแปด
เหมือนกับที่เราเคยมี
สำหรับกรณี N เท่ากับสี่ เหล่านี้คือเมทริกซ์ที่เราเชื่อมโยงกับ discrete Fourier transform
สำหรับแต่ละมิติ แต่เราเรียกมันว่า
quantum Fourier transform เมื่อเราต้องการคิด
ว่ามันเป็นการดำเนินการควอนตัม
บางครั้งตัวประกอบนำหน้าหนึ่งส่วนรากที่สองของ N จะไม่ถูกรวมไว้เมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ discrete Fourier
transform ว่าเป็นเมทริกซ์
แต่เราต้องการตัวประกอบนั้นที่นี่เพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าเราได้เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
บางครั้งก็มีเครื่องหมายลบในแต่ละเลขชี้กำลัง แต่ไม่เสมอไป
โดยพื้นฐานแล้วเป็นแค่ความชอบส่วนตัว ที่ไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง
ธรรมชาติพื้นฐานของ transform
แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม เราจะนิยาม quantum Fourier transform ตามที่เขียนไว้บนหน้าจอ
มีสัญกรณ์ย่อที่มีประโยชน์มาก
ที่ใช้กันทั่วไป และเราจะใช้มัน
ทีหลังในบทเรียน
นั่นคือนิยามจำนวน
เชิงซ้อน omega N อย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้
โดยเฉพาะคือ e ยกกำลัง สอง pi I หาร N ซึ่งสามารถเขียน
โดยใช้ sin และ cosine
ตามที่เรามีตรงนี้ บางครั้งเราเรียก
จำนวนนี้ว่ารากที่ N ของหนึ่ง เพราะเมื่อเรา
ยกกำลัง N เราจะได้หนึ่ง
นี่คือรูปที่แสดงตัวอย่างสองสามตัว
Omega หนึ่ง เท่ากับหนึ่ง omega สอง เท่ากับลบหนึ่ง และ omega สี่ เท่ากับ I
โดยทั่วไป เพื่อให้ได้ omega N เราสามารถจินตนาการการแบ่งวงกลมหน่วยเป็น N ชิ้นเท่ากัน เหมือนพิซซ่าที่แบ่งให้ N คน
และ omega N อยู่ที่
มุมของชิ้นแรก โดยสมมติว่ามุมอีกข้าง
ของชิ้นนั้นอยู่ที่หนึ่ง
ดังนั้นโดยเฉพาะเมื่อ N
ใหญ่ขึ้นเรื่อยๆ ชิ้นจะเล็กลงเรื่อยๆ และ omega N จะ
เข้าใกล้หนึ่งมากขึ้นเรื่อยๆ
และตอนนี้ถ้าเราใช้สัญกรณ์นั้น เราสามารถแสดง
quantum Fourier transform ในแบบที่สะอาดขึ้นเล็กน้อย
บางครั้งสัญกรณ์นี้
ช่วยให้ทุกอย่างง่ายขึ้นอย่างที่เราจะ
เห็นในภายหลังของบทเรียน
มี quantum circuit
ที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับ implement quantum Fourier transform
เมื่อ N เป็นกำลังของสอง
ซึ่งเราจะดูกันตอนนี้ แม้ว่าเรามักนิยาม
quantum Fourier transform สำหรับมิติ N ใดก็ได้
เราจะต้องการมัน
ในกรณีที่ N เป็นกำลังของสองเท่านั้น เพื่อขยาย
ขั้นตอน phase estimation
การ implement นี้จะใช้
controlled phase gate ซึ่งแสดงตามที่
เรามีบนหน้าจอ
มันดูเหมือน control
สองตัวเชื่อมต่อกัน พร้อมกับตัวเลข ซึ่งเป็น
alpha ในกรณีนี้
และการกระทำของ gate นี้อธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ที่แสดงตรงนี้
มันเป็น controlled phase
gate อย่างแท้จริง หมายความว่าเรามี control qubit ที่ควบคุม phase gate
เราเห็น phase gate ย้อนกลับไปในบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง
แต่สำหรับ phase gate โดยเฉพาะ มันไม่สำคัญ
ว่า qubit ไหนเป็น control และตัวไหนเป็น target
และเราเห็นสิ่งนั้นในบทเรียนที่สอง สำหรับกรณีเฉพาะของ Z gate
และตอนนี้ที่เรามีแนวคิดนั้นแล้ว เราสามารถไปต่อว่า
quantum Fourier transform สามารถ implement ได้ยังไง
การ implement เป็นแบบ recursive โดยธรรมชาติ และวิธีที่ง่ายที่สุดในการ
อธิบายมันอย่างง่ายๆ คือการยกตัวอย่าง
ที่สามารถขยายเป็นกรณีทั่วไปได้ง่าย
นี่คือวิธีทำ
เมื่อ N เท่ากับ 32
ดังนั้นมี qubit ห้าตัว
เพื่อความชัดเจน เราเชื่อมโยง
สถานะฐานมาตรฐานของ qubit ห้าตัวนี้กับจำนวนเต็มระหว่างศูนย์ถึง 31 โดยใช้สัญกรณ์ฐานสอง
สิ่งแรกที่เราทำคือทำ quantum Fourier
transform สำหรับ N เท่ากับ 16 กับ qubit ทั้งหมดยกเว้น
qubit ที่มีนัยสำคัญน้อยที่สุด
ซึ่งเป็นตัวที่อยู่ด้านบน และนั่นคือส่วน
recursive ของการสร้าง
ดังนั้นเพื่อ implement การดำเนินการนี้ เราต้องทำตาม
รูปแบบเดียวกันแต่ใช้ qubit น้อยลงหนึ่งตัว
และในกรณีฐาน เรา
มีแค่ qubit ตัวเดียว ซึ่ง quantum Fourier transform ก็แค่ Hadamard gate
เมื่อเราใช้ QFT กับ qubit ทั้งหมดยกเว้นตัวบนแล้ว เราใช้ controlled phase gate หลายตัวโดยใช้ phase ที่
ระบุไว้ในแผนภาพ
จากนั้นเราใช้ Hadamard
gate กับ qubit บน แล้วสลับ qubit รอบๆ เล็กน้อยโดยใช้ swap gate
swap gate เหล่านี้มีผลเป็นการเรียงสับเปลี่ยน qubit แบบวนรอบ ซึ่งจำเป็นเพื่อให้
การสร้างทำงานได้
เราสามารถทำตามรูปแบบเดียวกันสำหรับค่า N อื่นๆ
ที่เป็นกำลังของสอง โดยเราเริ่ม controlled phase gate เสมอ
ด้วย alpha เป็น pi หาร
สอง สำหรับ qubit ล่าง แล้วหารด้วยสองในแต่ละครั้ง
เลื่อนไปทางซ้ายในแผนภาพ
เพื่อให้ได้ phase ถัดไป มันไม่ชัดเจนเลย
ว่าการสร้างนี้ทำงานได้
และผมจะไม่อธิบาย
ว่าทำไมมันถึงใช้ได้ในวิดีโอนี้
ถ้าสนใจดูรายละเอียด
ว่าทำไมมันถึงใช้ได้ สามารถหาอ่านได้ใน
เนื้อหาเขียนของบทเรียน
ผมจะบอกว่าสิ่งที่
ถูกใช้ประโยชน์ที่นี่คือโครงสร้างพื้นฐานของ
discrete Fourier transform
และจริงๆ แล้วเป็น
โครงสร้างเดียวกันที่ทำให้ fast
Fourier transform ทำงานได้
อีกวิธีพูดคือ ถ้าเราดู fast Fourier transform เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับมันใน
แง่ของ quantum circuit
และนี่คือ circuit ที่เราได้
แล้วเราต้องการ gate ทั้งหมดกี่ตัวสำหรับการ implement นี้?
เพื่อหาคำตอบ ให้ SM เป็นจำนวน gate ที่
เราต้องการเมื่อเรามี M qubit
เมื่อ M เท่ากับหนึ่ง เราต้องการแค่ gate เดียว เพราะ QFT เป็นแค่การดำเนินการ Hadamard ในกรณีนี้
ถ้า M เป็นอย่างน้อยสอง เหล่านี้
คือ gate ที่เราต้องการ
ก่อนอื่นเราต้องการ SM ลบหนึ่ง gate สำหรับ quantum Fourier
transform บน M ลบหนึ่ง qubit ไม่ว่าจำนวนนั้นจะเป็นเท่าไร
เรายังต้องการ M ลบหนึ่ง
controlled phase gate, M ลบหนึ่ง swap gate
และ Hadamard gate เพิ่มอีกหนึ่งตัว
นี่คือนิพจน์ของ
SM ในทั้งสองกรณี เมื่อ M เท่ากับหนึ่ง และ
เมื่อ M เป็นอย่างน้อยสอง
นี่คือตัวอย่างของสิ่งที่เรียกว่าความสัมพันธ์เวียนเกิด และ
มันปรากฏบ่อยมากในการวิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึม
อันนี้โดยเฉพาะ
ค่อนข้างง่ายมาก และมันมีสิ่งที่เรียกว่า
นิพจน์รูปปิด ซึ่งเราได้จากการหาผลรวม
พูดให้แม่นยำ ค่าของ SM คือผลรวมของจำนวนคี่
ต่อเนื่อง M ตัวแรก ซึ่งเท่ากับ M กำลังสอง
อย่างที่เราอาจเคยเจอมาก่อนหรืออาจเพิ่งสังเกตเห็น
ในบางจุดของชีวิต
และมันค่อนข้างง่ายที่จะพิสูจน์สูตรนี้ด้วยอุปนัยบน M ใน
กรณีที่สนใจบทพิสูจน์แบบเป็นทางการ
แค่นั้นเอง เราสามารถ implement
quantum Fourier transform บน M qubit โดยใช้ M กำลังสอง gate
แค่หมายเหตุเพิ่มเติม
สั้นๆ สองสามข้อ
อย่างแรก จริงๆ แล้ว
เราไม่ต้องการ swap gate ทั้งหมดที่ผมอธิบาย
เป็นไปได้ที่จะผลัก
มันทั้งหมดไปไว้ท้ายสุด ตราบใดที่เราปรับว่า qubit ไหนที่ controlled phase gate
ทำงานด้วยอย่างเหมาะสม
และถ้าเราทำแบบนั้น เราจะ
ต้องการแค่ M หารสอง swap gate รวมทั้งหมด ปัดลง
เราจะยังมีต้นทุนแบบกำลังสอง แต่จำนวน gate สามารถลดลงได้ด้วยวิธีนี้
และหมายเหตุสุดท้ายคือ เราสามารถทำให้ต้นทุนน้อยลงได้อีกถ้าเรายอมรับ
การประมาณที่ดีพอสมควร
ตัวอย่างเช่น เมื่อ M ใหญ่ขึ้น controlled phase gate หลายตัวค่อนข้างใกล้
การดำเนินการ identity
และการตัดตัวที่ใกล้มาก
ออกสามารถประหยัด gate ได้ค่อนข้างมากในขณะที่ยังให้
การประมาณที่ดีพอสมควร
ก็เป็นไปได้ที่จะประมาณ quantum Fourier transform
ด้วย circuit ที่ตื้นมาก หมายถึงที่มีความลึกน้อย ในกรณีที่เรา
ต้องการทำแบบนั้น
และตอนนี้ที่เรารู้แล้วว่า
quantum Fourier transform คืออะไรสำหรับมิติต่างๆ รวมถึงวิธี implement มันเมื่อมิติเป็นกำลังของสอง
เราสามารถกลับไปที่
ขั้นตอน phase estimation และดูว่ามันสามารถขยายได้ยังไง โดยใช้จำนวน
M ใดก็ได้ของ control qubit
นี่คือหน้าตาของขั้นตอนเป็น quantum circuit สำหรับ
ค่า M ใดก็ได้ที่เลือก
เรามี M control qubit ด้านบน ซึ่งเราสมมติว่าทั้งหมด
ถูกตั้งค่าเริ่มต้นเป็นสถานะศูนย์
เราใช้ Hadamard
gate กับแต่ละตัว จากนั้นแต่ละตัว
ถูกใช้เป็น control qubit เพื่อใช้กำลังบางอย่างของ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารี U
โดยเราเพิ่มจำนวนครั้ง
ที่ใช้ U เป็นสองเท่าสำหรับแต่ละ control qubit
ในแผนภาพนี้ ผมระบุเรื่องนี้โดยใส่กำลัง
ของ U ไว้ในกล่อง แทนที่จะแสดง controlled U gate
ถูกใช้จำนวนครั้งนั้น เพื่อทำให้
แผนภาพชัดเจนขึ้นและประหยัดพื้นที่
ให้พอดีกับหน้าจอ
สิ่งแรกที่เราต้องสังเกต
เกี่ยวกับขั้นตอนนี้คือ มันอาจมีราคาแพงมาก
โดยเฉพาะเรากำลัง
เพิ่มจำนวนครั้งที่ใช้การดำเนินการ U เป็นสองเท่า
สำหรับแต่ละ control qubit
และถ้าวิธีที่เราทำคือแค่ทำ controlled U gate ซ้ำกี่ครั้งก็ตามที่ต้องการ
เราจะได้ circuit ที่ใหญ่มาก มันจะใหญ่แบบ
เอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลในจำนวน M
นั่นเป็นข้อจำกัดสำคัญโดยทั่วไป และโดยเฉพาะมันจำกัดความสามารถในการได้การประมาณ
ค่าเฉพาะที่แม่นยำ
ในกรณีเฉพาะของการแยกตัวประกอบ ซึ่งเราจะถึงเร็วๆ นี้ มันกลับเป็นว่าเราโชคดีมากและเราสามารถเล่นกลที่ทำให้
หลีกเลี่ยงการระเบิดของต้นทุนแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลนี้ได้
แต่โดยทั่วไปสำหรับ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารี U ใดก็ได้ สิ่งนี้จะเป็นไปไม่ได้ และ
เราจะต้องจ่ายราคาสูง
สำหรับการเพิ่ม
จำนวน control qubit
ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียด
การวิเคราะห์ circuit ในวิดีโอนี้ และจะแค่บอกว่ามีนิพจน์ที่ค่อนข้างง่าย
สำหรับสถานะ
ก่อนการวัดพอดี ซึ่งแสดงอยู่บนหน้าจอ
จากสถานะนั้นเราสามารถหานิพจน์สำหรับความน่าจะเป็น
ของผลลัพธ์ต่างๆ และมันดูเป็นแบบนี้
และเมื่อเรามีนิพจน์นี้
เราสามารถให้เหตุผลเกี่ยวกับมัน และจริงๆ แล้วนิพจน์นี้
คือทั้งหมดที่เราต้องการเพื่อดำเนินการต่อ
อย่างที่บอก ผมจะไม่ลง
รายละเอียดในวิดีโอนี้ แต่สามารถหาอ่านได้ใน
เนื้อหาเขียนของบทเรียน และมันกลับเป็นว่า
จริงๆ ไม่ได้ซับซ้อนมาก
ลองดูถ้าสนใจ ถ้าเราวิเคราะห์ สิ่งที่เราจะพบคือสถานการณ์
ไม่ได้ต่างจากกรณี M เท่ากับ
สอง มากนัก ยกเว้นว่าเราได้ความแม่นยำมากขึ้น
โดยเฉพาะ เราสามารถคิด
ก่อนเกี่ยวกับความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้การประมาณที่ดีที่สุด หรือหนึ่งใน
สองการประมาณที่ดีที่สุด
ซึ่งเราสามารถแสดงได้อย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้
เราสามารถไม่สนใจตัวห้อย หนึ่ง บนค่าสัมบูรณ์ก็ได้
นี่เป็นแค่สัญลักษณ์ที่เรา
สามารถใช้เตือนตัวเองว่าเรากำลังพูดถึง
การประมาณบนวงกลม ที่เราคิดว่า theta เท่ากับศูนย์
กับ theta เท่ากับหนึ่งเป็นสิ่งเดียวกัน ประเด็นคือ
เราคิดเกี่ยวกับค่า Y ที่ทำให้ Y หารด้วยสองยกกำลัง M
ใกล้ theta มากที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้
และอีกครั้ง เหมือนกับที่
เราเคยมีสำหรับกรณี M เท่ากับสอง เราได้รับการรับประกันว่าจะได้ผลลัพธ์ Y นี้ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นอย่างน้อย 40%
จริงๆ แล้ว ความน่าจะเป็นอย่างน้อย
สี่หาร pi กำลังสอง ซึ่งมากกว่า 40% เล็กน้อย
10 ก็เป็นค่าประมาณที่ไม่เลว
ของ pi กำลังสอง เมื่อเรารีบ
และนั่นน่าทึ่งมากจริงๆ สิ่งที่เราพูดถึงคือการได้
การประมาณ theta ที่ดีที่สุดเป็นเศษส่วน Y หารด้วยสองยกกำลัง M
ที่ Y เป็นจำนวนเต็ม และเราได้
การประมาณที่ดีที่สุดด้วยความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า 40%
เราก็สามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
การประมาณที่แย่กว่าได้
โดยเฉพาะ มาจินตนาการ
ว่า Y ไม่ค่อยดีนัก และพูดให้เฉพาะเจาะจงมาสมมติ
ว่ามีการประมาณ
theta ในรูปแบบเดียวกันที่ดีกว่า อยู่ระหว่าง theta กับ Y หารด้วยสองยกกำลัง M
ซึ่งสามารถแสดงได้ตาม
ที่เขียนบนหน้าจอ
ในกรณีเช่นนั้น
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ Y นี้จะค่อนข้างน้อย ไม่เกิน 25%
จริงๆ มันจะต่ำกว่านั้น แต่ 25% คือสิ่งที่เราได้จาก
การวิเคราะห์ที่ค่อนข้างง่าย แต่ก็ดีพอ
เป็นตัวอย่าง นี่คือกราฟที่เราได้เมื่อใช้ control
qubit สามตัวแทนที่จะเป็นสอง
คราวนี้ผมแค่พล็อต
ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับผลลัพธ์สาม สี่ และห้า เพราะผมไม่ต้องการให้
รูปรกเกินไป
เมื่อ theta เท่ากับ
ครึ่งหนึ่ง เป็นต้น เราได้รับการรับประกันว่าจะได้ผลลัพธ์สี่
ดังนั้นเราเอาค่า
ประมาณเป็นสี่หารแปด หรือครึ่งหนึ่ง เพราะสองยกกำลัง
สามเท่ากับแปด
และในกรณีนี้เราถูกต้องพอดี และตราบใดที่ theta ใกล้ครึ่งหนึ่งมากกว่าสาม
ในแปด เป็นต้น
เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์สี่ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสูงกว่า
ผลลัพธ์สาม
และด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
อีกครั้ง มากกว่า 40%
นี่คือกราฟเมื่อ M เท่ากับสี่ และเส้นโค้ง
ดูเหมือนกันทีเดียว ยกเว้นว่าตอนนี้เรา
ซูมเข้าไปสองเท่า
ดังนั้นตอนนี้ผลลัพธ์ที่พล็อตรวมถึง เจ็ด แปด และเก้า และเราเอาค่าประมาณเป็นหนึ่งในจำนวนเหล่านี้
หารด้วย 16 แทนที่จะเป็นแปด
และผมจะแสดงอีกหนึ่งกราฟที่เราเพิ่มเป็น M เท่ากับห้า
และอีกครั้ง เราจะ
ซูมเข้าไปสองเท่า
และนี่ไง อีกครั้ง เส้นโค้งดู
เหมือนกันทีเดียว แต่เรากำลัง
เพิ่มความแม่นยำเป็นสองเท่าอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
และเหมือนก่อน เราได้การประมาณ theta ที่ดีที่สุด ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นมากกว่า 40%
นั่นน่าทึ่งมาก แต่ถ้า 40% ไม่ดีพอ
เป็นตัววัดความมั่นใจ
สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือรันขั้นตอนจำนวนน้อยครั้ง และ
เอาค่าฐานนิยมของผลลัพธ์ หมายถึงค่าที่
ปรากฏบ่อยที่สุด
และถ้าเราทำแบบนั้น เราจะมีโอกาสสูงมากที่จะลงเอยด้วยการประมาณ theta ที่ดีมาก
จำไว้ด้วยว่าทุกครั้งที่เรารัน
ขั้นตอน phase estimation เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ
จะออกมาไม่เปลี่ยนแปลง
ดังนั้นมันพร้อมให้เราใช้รันขั้นตอน
หลายครั้งแบบนี้
สรุปสั้นๆ เรากำลังเก็บ
สถิติเกี่ยวกับ theta และประเด็นคือ โดยการทำแบบนี้เราจะได้การประมาณ
theta ที่แม่นยำมาก
ด้วยความมั่นใจสูงมาก และเราไม่ต้องการรอบมากมายของขั้นตอนเพื่อทำเรื่องนี้
และนั่นคือวิธีที่ขั้นตอน
phase estimation ทำงาน
ในส่วนสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะนำเทคนิค
phase estimation ไปใช้กับปัญหาการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
อย่างที่ผมกล่าวไว้ตอนต้นวิดีโอ วิธีการทำงานคือเราพิจารณาปัญหาตัวกลางที่เรียกว่าปัญหาการหาอันดับ
เราจะดูว่าเราสามารถ
แก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับโดยใช้ phase estimation ได้ยังไง จากนั้นเราจะพูดสั้นๆ ว่าการแก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับ
ช่วยให้เราแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพยังไง
ส่วนที่สองเป็นแบบคลาสสิกทั้งหมด และผมจะแค่สรุป
แนวคิดพื้นฐานในวิดีโอนี้
แต่มาเริ่มด้วย
ปัญหาการหาอันดับกัน
ก่อนอื่น มาตั้ง
สัญกรณ์ที่มีประโยชน์กัน
สำหรับจำนวนเต็มบวก N ทุกตัว เรานิยาม ZN เป็นจำนวนเต็ม
ศูนย์ถึง N ลบหนึ่ง
ตัวอย่างเช่น Z หนึ่ง มี
สมาชิกตัวเดียวคือศูนย์ Z สอง มีสมาชิกศูนย์กับหนึ่ง
Z สาม มีสมาชิก ศูนย์
หนึ่ง และสอง เป็นต้น
ดังนั้น ZN เป็นเซต
แต่เราก็สามารถคิดว่า
มันเป็นมากกว่าเซต เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการทางคณิตศาสตร์เช่นการบวกและการคูณบน ZN
โดยนิยามมัน modular N
ตัวอย่างเช่น สมมติว่า
N เท่ากับเจ็ด
เรามีว่าสามและห้า
เป็นสมาชิกของ Z เจ็ด และถ้าเราคูณกันจะได้ 15
ซึ่งเหลือเศษหนึ่ง
เมื่อหารด้วยเจ็ด
บางครั้งเราแสดงสิ่งนี้โดยเขียนว่า สามคูณห้า
เท่ากับหนึ่ง mod เจ็ด อย่างที่เขียนไว้ตรงนี้
แต่เราก็สามารถเขียนง่ายๆ ว่า สามคูณห้าเท่ากับหนึ่ง
แน่นอนว่าสามคูณห้า
ปกติไม่เท่ากับหนึ่ง มันเท่ากับ 15
แต่เมื่อชัดเจนว่า
เราทำงานใน Z เจ็ด หมายความว่าการคูณ
นิยาม modular เจ็ด
เราสามารถเขียนง่ายๆ ว่า
สามคูณห้าเท่ากับหนึ่ง
ในบรรดาสมาชิก
ของ ZN สำหรับ N บวกใดๆ บางตัวจะมี
GCD เท่ากับหนึ่งกับ N
และบางตัวไม่ และสมาชิกที่มี GCD เท่ากับหนึ่งกับ N นั้นพิเศษ
และเราเขียน ZN star เพื่ออ้างถึงเซตของสมาชิกเหล่านี้เท่านั้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ Z 21 star
ในบรรดาสมาชิกของ Z 21 ซึ่งมี 21 ตัวแน่นอน มี 12 ตัวที่มี GCD เท่ากับหนึ่ง
กับ 21 และที่เหลือไม่มี
โดยเฉพาะเมื่อใดก็ตาม
ที่เรามีสมาชิกของ Z 21 ที่หารด้วย
สามหรือเจ็ดลงตัว เราข้ามมัน
มีหลายเหตุผล
ที่เซตนี้พิเศษ และเหตุผลหนึ่งคือ เมื่อใดก็ตามที่เรามีสมาชิกของ ZN star
และเราพิจารณากำลัง
จำนวนเต็มบวกของตัวเลขนั้น เราจะได้
ตัวเลขหนึ่งเสมอในที่สุด
ที่เหมือนก่อน เราพูดถึงการคูณ modular N
กำลังจำนวนเต็มบวกที่น้อยที่สุดที่ให้เราได้หนึ่งเรียกว่า
อันดับของสมาชิกนั้น
ตัวอย่างเช่น ลองคิดเกี่ยวกับสมาชิก A เท่ากับสี่ ใน Z 21 star
สี่คูณสี่เท่ากับ 16 ซึ่งไม่เท่ากับหนึ่ง modular 21 แต่ถ้าเราคูณด้วยสี่อีกครั้ง
เราจะได้ 64 และ 64 modular
21 เท่ากับหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นอันดับของสี่ modular 21 คือสาม
การไปถึงหนึ่งแบบนี้เกิดขึ้นเสมอสำหรับทุกสมาชิกของ ZN star
และยังไงก็ตาม มันไม่เคย
เกิดขึ้นสำหรับสมาชิกของ ZN ที่ไม่อยู่ใน ZN star
ดังนั้นการมี GCD เท่ากับ
หนึ่งกับ N แบบนี้เป็นทั้งเงื่อนไขจำเป็น
และเพียงพอสำหรับเรื่องนี้
และเพื่อจบตัวอย่างของ
N เท่ากับ 21 นี่คือกำลัง
จำนวนเต็มบวกที่น้อยที่สุดที่ใช้ได้สำหรับ
แต่ละสมาชิกของ Z 21 star
และสามารถตรวจสอบได้ทีละตัว
และตอนนี้เราสามารถระบุ
ปัญหาการหาอันดับ ซึ่งก็คือการหาอันดับสำหรับสมาชิกที่กำหนดใน ZN star
พูดให้แม่นยำ อินพุตคือ
จำนวนเต็มบวก A และ N ที่ GCD เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และเอาต์พุตคือ
จำนวนเต็มบวกที่น้อยที่สุด R ที่ A ยกกำลัง R
เท่ากับหนึ่ง modular N
หรือเทียบเท่ากับ
จำนวนเต็มบวกที่น้อยที่สุด R ที่ A ยกกำลัง R เท่ากับหนึ่ง
โดยสมมติว่าเราทำเลขคณิตใน ZN
เชื่อกันว่านี่เป็น
ปัญหาที่ยากในเชิงคำนวณ ไม่มีอัลกอริทึมคลาสสิก
ที่มีประสิทธิภาพที่ทราบสำหรับแก้มัน
และอย่างที่เราจะพูดถึง ปัญหานี้ยากอย่างน้อยเท่ากับ
การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม ในแง่ที่ว่า ถ้าเรามีอัลกอริทึมสำหรับแก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับ
เราจะสามารถใช้อัลกอริทึมนั้นแก้ปัญหา
การแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
จริงๆ แล้วมันเป็นไปในทางกลับกันด้วย หมายความว่า ถ้าเรามีอัลกอริทึมสำหรับแยกตัวประกอบ เราสามารถใช้มันแก้
ปัญหาการหาอันดับ
ดังนั้นสองปัญหานี้
เทียบเท่ากันในแง่ของ
ความยากเชิงคำนวณ
ตอนนี้เราจะดูว่าเราสามารถ
แก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับบนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
โดยใช้ phase estimation ได้ยังไง
เพื่อเชื่อมโยงระหว่างปัญหา มาจินตนาการว่าเรามีระบบที่เซตสถานะคลาสสิกคือ ZN
สำหรับสมาชิก A ใดก็ได้ใน ZN star เราจะนิยามการดำเนินการ
MA อย่างที่เรามีตรงนี้
ในคำพูด สิ่งที่ MA ทำคือคูณด้วย A และการคูณนี้เป็น modular N
และสำหรับส่วนที่เหลือของบทเรียน ควรคิดว่า
นิพจน์ภายใน ket ถูกคำนวณ modular N เสมอ
เพื่อให้ทุกอย่างง่ายและเราไม่ต้อง
เขียน mod N ซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่า
นี่เป็นการดำเนินการยูนิทารี แต่นั่นเป็นจริง
เพราะ A อยู่ใน ZN star เท่านั้น
ถ้า GCD ของ A กับ N ไม่ใช่หนึ่ง การดำเนินการนี้จะไม่เป็นยูนิทารี
นี่คือตัวอย่าง ถ้า N เท่ากับ 15 และ A เท่ากับสอง ซึ่งอยู่ใน Z 15 star
นี่คือการกระทำของ M สอง
และถ้าตรวจสอบ
ตัวอย่างนี้สักครู่ จะเห็นว่าสมาชิกของ ZN ถูกสลับโดยการกระทำนี้
ดังนั้นมันทั้ง deterministic และ unitary พูดอีกอย่างคือ เป็นเมทริกซ์ MA เป็นเมทริกซ์การเรียงสับเปลี่ยน
และนี่คือแนวคิดหลัก ค่าเฉพาะของ MA มีความเชื่อมโยง
อย่างใกล้ชิด
กับอันดับของ A และโดยการใช้ phase estimation เพื่อประมาณค่าเฉพาะ
เหล่านี้ใกล้พอ
เราสามารถหาอันดับของ A ได้ แล้วเวกเตอร์เฉพาะและค่าเฉพาะของ MA คืออะไรกันแน่?
เราไม่ต้องการทั้งหมด เราต้องการแค่บางส่วน
มาเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่างง่ายๆ
นี่คือเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของ MA เราตั้งชื่อมันว่า psi ศูนย์ และมันเท่ากับ
ผลรวมของ ket หนึ่ง, ket a,
ket A กำลังสอง เรื่อยไปจนถึง ket A ยกกำลัง R ลบหนึ่ง ทั้งหมดหารด้วยรากที่สองของ R
เพื่อทำให้เป็นเวกเตอร์หน่วย ที่นี่ R คืออันดับของ A
และผมจะสงวนตัวอักษร
R ไว้สำหรับอันดับของ A ในส่วนที่เหลือของบทเรียน
ดังนั้นเมื่อใดก็ตามที่เห็น R นั่นคืออันดับของ A
สำหรับ A ใดก็ตามที่เรากำลังพูดถึง
ค่าเฉพาะที่เชื่อมโยง
กับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะนี้คือหนึ่ง
และเราสามารถยืนยันได้โดย
ใช้ MA กับเวกเตอร์นี้เพื่อดูว่าได้อะไร
MA คูณด้วย A ดังนั้น
เราแค่ต้องเพิ่มเลขชี้กำลังแต่ละตัว
ขึ้นหนึ่ง และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราได้
แต่อันดับของ A คือ R ดังนั้น A ยกกำลัง R เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และเราสามารถแทนค่านั้นได้
แต่นั่นเป็นเวกเตอร์เดียวกับ
ที่เราเริ่มต้น เราแค่
สลับ ket รอบๆ แต่เราหาผลรวมอยู่
ดังนั้นมันไม่เปลี่ยนอะไร
ดังนั้น MA คูณ psi ศูนย์ เท่ากับ psi ศูนย์
มันจึงเป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของ
MA ที่มีค่าเฉพาะหนึ่ง
นั่นเป็นตัวอย่างที่ง่ายมาก
ของเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ และเพื่อระบุเวกเตอร์เฉพาะเพิ่มเติม มาระลึกสัญกรณ์เดียวกับที่เราเคยมีก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน
Omega R คือจำนวน
เชิงซ้อนบนวงกลมหน่วยที่ได้จากการเอา E ยกกำลัง
สอง คูณ pi คูณ I
หาร R ครั้งก่อนเรามี N แทน R แต่มันทำงาน
เหมือนกันสำหรับ R แทนที่ N
เราต้องการจำนวนนี้เพราะ
มันจะปรากฏในเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ
อื่นๆ ของ MA ที่เราจะระบุ
และตอนนี้ที่เราระลึกสัญกรณ์นั้นแล้ว เราสามารถสังเกตว่า
เวกเตอร์นี้ที่ตั้งชื่อว่า psi หนึ่ง ก็เป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะของ MA ด้วย
มันคล้ายกับ psi ศูนย์ เรามี ket เดียวกันทั้งหมดและเราหาผลรวมแล้ว
หารด้วยรากที่สองของ R
แต่คราวนี้เรามี phase ต่างๆ คูณแต่ละ ket
Omega R ยกกำลังลบหนึ่ง สำหรับ A, omega R ยกกำลังลบสอง สำหรับ A กำลังสอง เรื่อยไปจนถึง omega R ยกกำลัง
ลบ R ลบหนึ่ง
สำหรับ A ยกกำลัง R ลบหนึ่ง ดังนั้นกำลังของ omega R
จะเป็นลบหนึ่งเสมอคูณกำลังของ A
ที่ปรากฏภายใน ket
ผมจะไม่ลงรายละเอียด แต่มันแสดงอยู่บนหน้าจอในกรณีที่ต้องการดูวิดีโอซ้ำแล้วหยุดตามต้องการ
แต่ถ้าเราทำการคูณและทำให้ง่ายขึ้นอีกครั้ง โดยใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า A ยกกำลัง R เท่ากับหนึ่ง
รวมถึงข้อเท็จจริงสำคัญมากที่ว่า omega ยกกำลัง R เท่ากับหนึ่ง สิ่งที่เราจะพบคือ
เราได้เวกเตอร์เฉพาะของ MA อีกครั้ง
คราวนี้เมื่อเราทำให้ง่ายขึ้น เราจะต้องดึงตัวประกอบ omega R ออกมาเพื่อเห็นว่ามันเป็นเวกเตอร์เฉพาะจริงๆ
และตัวประกอบ omega R นั้นแสดงค่าเฉพาะที่เชื่อมโยงกับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะนี้
นั่นคือคู่เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ
ค่าเฉพาะตัวที่สองของ MA
เราสามารถระบุเวกเตอร์เฉพาะเพิ่มเติมโดยใช้เหตุผลเดียวกันทุกประการ และจริงๆ แล้ว ถ้าเราแค่แทนที่ omega R
ด้วย omega R ยกกำลัง J สำหรับแต่ละ J ระหว่างศูนย์ถึง R ลบหนึ่ง เราจะได้เวกเตอร์เฉพาะเสมอ
และค่าเฉพาะที่เชื่อมโยงจะเป็น omega R ยกกำลัง J
ดังนั้นนี่รวม psi ศูนย์
และ psi หนึ่ง ที่เราเห็นแล้ว
รวมถึง R ลบสอง คู่เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ ค่าเฉพาะ อื่นๆ
มันทำงานเหมือนกันโดยพื้นฐาน และเพื่อยืนยัน เราแค่ต้องรู้ว่า A ยกกำลัง R เท่ากับหนึ่ง
รวมถึง omega R ยกกำลัง
R เท่ากับหนึ่ง
มีเวกเตอร์เฉพาะอื่นๆ ของ MA เช่น ket ศูนย์ เป็นต้น แต่มันจะไม่เป็นประโยชน์กับเราและเราไม่ต้องกังวลเกี่ยวกับมัน
เราต้องกังวลแค่ psi ศูนย์ ถึง psi R ลบหนึ่ง
มาโฟกัสที่ psi หนึ่ง สักครู่ เพื่อพยายามเข้าใจว่าทำไมเราถึงสนใจเวกเตอร์เฉพาะเหล่านี้
และมันบอกอะไรเรา
เกี่ยวกับอันดับ R ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เราพยายามหา
สมมติว่าเราได้รับ
เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi หนึ่ง เราสามารถพยายาม
หา R ได้ดังนี้
อย่างแรก เราทำ phase
estimation กับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะนี้โดยใช้ quantum circuit ที่
implement การดำเนินการ MA
สิ่งที่เราได้คือค่าประมาณของ theta ซึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่งหาร R ในกรณีนี้
และอย่างที่สอง เพราะเรากำลังหา R และเรามี
ค่าประมาณของหนึ่งหาร R สิ่งที่เป็นธรรมชาติคือ
คำนวณส่วนกลับ
แล้วปัดเศษเป็น
จำนวนเต็มที่ใกล้ที่สุด เราต้องปัดเศษแบบนี้
เพราะ R ต้องเป็นจำนวนเต็ม
แต่เราไม่มีหนึ่งหาร R พอดี เราแค่มีค่าประมาณ
แต่ถ้าค่าประมาณดีพอ เราจะได้ R เมื่อปัดเศษ
ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เราหา
และตอนนี้คำถามคือ เราต้องการความแม่นยำเท่าไรเพื่อหา R ที่ถูกต้องโดยคำนวณส่วนกลับแล้วปัดเศษ?
หรือพูดอีกอย่าง ค่าประมาณของเรา
ต้องแม่นยำแค่ไหนเพื่อให้ทั้งหมดทำงานได้?
มันกลับเป็นว่าเราต้องการค่าประมาณที่ค่อนข้างแม่นยำ
ตัวอย่างเช่น เราไม่
สามารถสับสนหนึ่งหาร R กับหนึ่งหาร R บวกหนึ่ง หรือหนึ่งหาร R ลบหนึ่ง เป็นต้น
ในเศษส่วนสองตัวนั้น หนึ่งหาร R บวกหนึ่ง
กับหนึ่งหาร R ลบหนึ่ง ค่อนข้างใกล้กับหนึ่ง
หาร R เมื่อ R ใหญ่
แต่แม้ว่าเราต้องการ
ค่าประมาณที่ค่อนข้างแม่นยำ เราไม่ต้องการค่าประมาณ
ที่แม่นยำอย่างน่าขัน และสามารถแสดงได้ว่า
ถ้าค่าประมาณ
เป็นไปตามอสมการที่
เรามีบนหน้าจอ การปัดเศษ
จะให้คำตอบที่ถูกต้อง
ผมจะไม่พยายามอธิบายเรื่องนั้นในวิดีโอนี้ แต่มันแสดงอยู่ใน
เนื้อหาเขียนของบทเรียน ในกรณีที่สนใจรายละเอียด
และถ้านั่นคือความแม่นยำ
ที่เราต้องการ ก็เพียงพอที่จะใช้
จำนวน control qubit ในขั้นตอน phase estimation
เท่ากับสองเท่าของ
ความยาวของ N บวกหนึ่ง
ที่อย่างที่เราเคยมีในบทเรียนก่อนๆ ความยาวของ N คือจำนวนบิตที่เราต้องแสดง N ในฐานสอง
ยังไงก็ตาม ถ้าเราพอใจ
ที่จะได้ค่าประมาณที่ดีที่สุดด้วยความน่าจะเป็นอย่างน้อย 40% และเราไม่พยายามเพิ่ม
ความมั่นใจ
อย่างที่ผมอธิบายก่อนหน้า เราจริงๆ ไม่ต้องการบวกหนึ่ง
แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม เรามีว่าจำนวน
control qubit ที่เราต้องการเป็นเชิงเส้นในความยาวของ N
ที่เขียนเป็นสตริงฐานสอง
เราเห็นแล้วว่าถ้าเรามี
เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi หนึ่ง เราสามารถใช้ phase estimation เพื่อหา R ถ้าเราใช้ความแม่นยำเพียงพอ
แต่โชคไม่ดีที่มันไม่ง่ายที่จะได้เวกเตอร์เฉพาะนี้มา
มาถามคำถามอื่นกัน
สมมติว่าเราไม่มี psi หนึ่ง แต่มี psi J
สำหรับ J ที่สุ่มมา
เราจะยังหา R ได้ไหม? หรืออย่างน้อยเราสามารถ
หาบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ R ได้ไหม?
และคำตอบคือใช่ เราสามารถหาบางอย่าง
เกี่ยวกับ R ได้ อย่างน้อยโดยเฉลี่ย
สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือพยายาม
หา J หาร R โดยใช้วิธีที่คล้ายกัน
มากกับที่เราเพิ่งเห็น
แต่มีข้อแตกต่างสำคัญ
อย่างแรก เราจะทำสิ่ง
เดียวกันกับที่เคยทำ ซึ่งก็คือรัน
ขั้นตอน phase estimation กับเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi J
และสิ่งที่เราจะได้คือ
ค่าประมาณของ J หาร R แทนที่จะเป็นหนึ่งหาร R
ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เราเคยมีก่อน
แต่ตอนนี้เรามีปัญหาเล็กน้อย เพราะการคำนวณ
ส่วนกลับจะไม่ให้ R แต่จะให้ R หาร J
และยังไงก็ตาม เราไม่ได้
สมมติว่าเรารู้ว่า J คืออะไร เราแค่ได้รับ psi J สำหรับ J สุ่ม
และเราไม่ได้ถูกบอกว่า J คืออะไร แล้วเราจะทำอะไรได้?
มันกลับเป็นว่ามีอัลกอริทึม
คลาสสิกที่รู้จักกันดีที่ช่วยเราได้ เรียกว่า
อัลกอริทึมเศษส่วนต่อเนื่อง
และสิ่งที่อัลกอริทึมนี้ทำได้คือเอาค่าประมาณของเรา
Y หารด้วยสองยกกำลัง M แล้วบอกเราว่าเศษส่วน U หาร V ตัวไหน
ที่เขียนในรูปต่ำสุด และทั้ง U กับ V เป็น
จำนวนเต็มที่น้อยกว่า N ที่ใกล้กับค่าประมาณของเรามากที่สุด
มันเป็นอัลกอริทึมที่น่าสนใจมาก และถ้าสนใจ ควรลองดูเลย
มันเชื่อมโยงอย่างใกล้ชิดกับอัลกอริทึมของ Euclid สำหรับ
คำนวณ GCD จริงๆ
แต่ผมจะไม่พูดอะไรเพิ่ม
เกี่ยวกับมันในวิดีโอนี้
ประเด็นคือ ถ้าเรามีค่า
ประมาณที่ดีของเศษส่วนบางตัวที่ตัวเศษ
และตัวส่วนไม่ได้ใหญ่เกินไป
อัลกอริทึมสามารถกู้คืนเศษส่วนได้ และนั่นคือสิ่งที่เราทำที่นี่
และตอนนี้เราเหลือคำถาม
เดียวกันกับก่อน ซึ่งก็คือเราต้องการความแม่นยำเท่าไร?
และมันกลับเป็นว่า
ขอบเขตเดียวกันกับที่เราเคยมีก่อนใช้ได้ในกรณีนี้
ดังนั้นการเลือก M ใน
แบบเดียวกับก่อนก็ใช้ได้ที่นี่เช่นกัน
ตอนนี้สิ่งนี้ไม่จำเป็นต้อง
บอกเรา R
สิ่งที่เราจะรู้ถ้าเราใช้
ความแม่นยำเพียงพอ คือ J หาร R แต่นั่นจะเป็น
เศษส่วนในรูปต่ำสุด
ดังนั้นเราอาจโชคร้ายในแง่ที่ว่า J ที่สุ่มมาอาจมีตัวประกอบร่วมกับ R
และมันจะถูกซ่อนจากเรา ในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุดเป็นต้น เราอาจได้ J เท่ากับศูนย์ และเราจะไม่รู้อะไรเลย
แต่นั่นเป็นกรณีเดียวจริงๆ
ที่เราไม่รู้อะไรเลย
โดยทั่วไป เราจะอย่างน้อย
ได้ตัวประกอบที่ไม่ธรรมดาของ R และถ้าเราสามารถสุ่มตัวอย่าง
และได้ psi J สำหรับ J ต่างๆ เราสามารถ
กู้คืน R ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสูงโดยคำนวณตัวคูณร่วมน้อย
ของตัวส่วนทั้งหมด
ที่เราสังเกตได้ และจริงๆ แล้ว
ไม่ต้องการตัวอย่างมากมายเลย
สรุปคือ J ที่เลือกบางตัวจะซ่อนตัวประกอบของ R แต่ J ที่สุ่ม
จะไม่สามารถซ่อน
ตัวประกอบของ R ได้นาน
นั่นคือแนวคิด เหลือแค่พิจารณาการ implement และโดยเฉพาะ
หาว่าต้นทุนเป็นเท่าไร
แก่นของแนวคิด ในการคำนวณอันดับของ
สมาชิก A ใน ZN star คือใช้ขั้นตอน phase estimation
กับการดำเนินการ MA
มาหาว่าต้นทุนของ
การทำเรื่องนี้เป็นฟังก์ชันของความยาวของ N ตัวใหญ่ ซึ่งผมจะเรียกว่า n ตัวเล็ก
นี่คือ circuit สำหรับ phase estimation เราจะต้องการ n ตัวเล็ก qubit ในส่วนล่างของ circuit
เพื่อเข้ารหัสสมาชิกของ ZN ในฐานสอง ดังนั้นเรามี M control qubit ด้านบนและ n ตัวเล็ก qubit ด้านล่าง
ซึ่งดีเพราะมันตรงกับชื่อที่เรา
ใช้ก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน
เพื่อนับจำนวน
gate ที่เราต้องการสำหรับ circuit ทั้งหมด มาโฟกัสก่อนที่ต้นทุนของการดำเนินการยูนิทารีแบบ controlled
ถ้าเราใช้เทคนิค
จากบทเรียนก่อน บทเรียนที่หก เราสามารถ implement MA โดยใช้ big O ของ n ตัวเล็กกำลังสอง gate
โดยใช้อัลกอริทึมคลาสสิกที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับเลขคณิต modular N
ผมจะข้ามรายละเอียดในวิดีโอนี้ แต่เหมือนหลาย
สิ่งอื่นที่ผมพูดถึง สามารถอ่านเพิ่มเติมได้ในเนื้อหาเขียนของบทเรียน
แต่ไม่เพียงพอที่จะ
implement แค่ MA
เราต้อง implement MA กำลังสอง, MA กำลังสี่, กำลัง
แปด, และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ
จนถึง MA ยกกำลังที่เป็นเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลใน M
และเรารู้ว่าเราจะต้องเอา M ให้เป็นเชิงเส้นใน n ตัวเล็ก
เพื่อให้ได้ความแม่นยำเพียงพอ
นี่เป็นข้อกังวลใหญ่
และผมเคยยกมันขึ้นมาก่อน
ถ้าเราจะ implement กำลัง
ของ MA โดยแค่ทำ MA ซ้ำ เราจะมีปัญหาเพราะการทำซ้ำ MA
ทั้งหมดจะมีต้นทุนเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
โชคดีที่เราสามารถเล่นกลเพื่อหลีกเลี่ยงการระเบิดของต้นทุนนี้
สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือดังนี้ สำหรับแต่ละกำลัง K ที่เราต้องการ
อย่างแรก เราคำนวณ A ยกกำลัง
K modular N
นี่คือปัญหาการยกกำลัง modular ที่ผมกล่าวถึงในบทเรียนที่หก
และมันสามารถแก้ได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ และนี่คือสิ่งที่เราทำได้ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิก
การคำนวณนี้ไม่
จำเป็นต้องทำด้วย quantum circuit เลย
ให้ B เป็นผลลัพธ์
ดังนั้น B เป็นสมาชิกของ ZN star
และอย่างที่สอง แทนที่จะใช้ MA ยกกำลัง K เราแค่ใช้ circuit สำหรับ MB
แค่นั้นเอง B เป็นแค่สมาชิกของ ZN star ดังนั้นต้นทุนในการ implement MB
คือ big O ของ n ตัวเล็กกำลังสอง
สรุปสั้นๆ สิ่งที่เราทำคือยกกำลังใน ZN แทนที่จะยกกำลัง
quantum circuit
แต่การดำเนินการจริงที่เราได้
ก็เหมือนกันทั้งสองทาง มันแค่คูณด้วย A, K ครั้ง
นี่เป็นเหมือนปาฏิหาริย์จริงๆ และเราจะไม่สามารถ
แก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับหรือแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
ด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ถ้าไม่ใช่เพราะเรื่องนี้
และตอนนี้ที่เรารู้ว่าแต่ละ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีแบบ controlled รวมถึงกำลังต่างๆ สามารถ implement ได้
ที่ต้นทุน big O ของ n กำลังสอง เราสามารถนับจำนวน
gate ทั้งหมดที่เราต้องการ
เรามี M Hadamard gate และเพราะ M เท่ากับ
big O ของ n ตัวเล็ก ต้นทุนคือ big O ของ n ตัวเล็ก
เรามี M การดำเนินการยูนิทารีแบบ controlled ที่แต่ละตัวมีต้นทุน big O ของ n กำลังสอง
ดังนั้นต้นทุนรวมตรงนี้
คือ big O ของ n กำลังสาม
และสุดท้าย quantum Fourier transform มีต้นทุน big O ของ n กำลังสอง
ดังนั้นต้นทุนรวมคือ big O ของ n กำลังสาม
โดยเฉพาะ เราจะเห็นว่าแม้จะใช้กล
การยกกำลัง modular ต้นทุนของการดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีแบบ controlled ก็ครอบงำ
แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม ต้นทุน
เป็นพหุนามใน n ตัวเล็ก
นอกจากนี้ยังมีการคำนวณ
คลาสสิกบางอย่างที่ต้องทำ เช่น การคำนวณการยกกำลัง modular และรัน
อัลกอริทึมเศษส่วนต่อเนื่อง
แต่การคำนวณเหล่านั้น
ก็มีต้นทุนพหุนามเช่นกัน และจริงๆ แล้วสามารถทำได้ใน big O ของ n กำลังสามเช่นกัน
มีเรื่องเดียวที่เหลืออยู่ และนั่นคือเราต้องหาเวกเตอร์เฉพาะมาให้ได้
เราจะทำได้ยังไง?
คำตอบจริงๆ ง่ายมาก เราไม่ได้รัน circuit
บนเวกเตอร์เฉพาะ
เราแค่รันมันบนสถานะ หนึ่ง หมายถึงการเข้ารหัส
ฐานสองของตัวเลขหนึ่ง ซึ่งเราคิดว่า
เป็นสมาชิกของ ZN
มาทำการแทนที่นั้น
ในแผนภาพ
เหตุผลที่มันใช้ได้คือเพราะสมการนี้ตรงนี้
สถานะ ket หนึ่ง จริงๆ แล้ว
เป็น superposition แบบสม่ำเสมอของ R เวกเตอร์เฉพาะที่
เราพูดถึง
และนั่นไม่ชัดเจนทันที แต่ถ้าคำนวณ
ผลรวม ควรจะได้ ket หนึ่ง
และถ้าเรารัน circuit บนสถานะนี้ เอาต์พุตที่เราจะได้
จะเหมือนกันทุกประการกับที่เราสุ่มเลือก J
แล้วรันขั้นตอนบน
เวกเตอร์เฉพาะ psi J
อีกครั้ง นั่นไม่ชัดเจน แต่การวิเคราะห์เปิดเผยว่ามันเป็นจริง
และสุดท้าย แค่นั้นเอง เรามีอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับการหาอันดับ
เหลืออีกส่วนสั้นๆ สุดท้าย
ของบทเรียน และเกี่ยวข้องกับความสัมพันธ์ระหว่างการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
กับการหาอันดับ
ผมกล่าวไว้ว่า ถ้าเราแก้ปัญหาการหาอันดับได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ เราก็สามารถแยก
ตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็มได้อย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
และผมอยากจะบอกแนวคิดหลักสั้นๆ ว่ามันทำงานยังไง
มันเป็นแบบคลาสสิกทั้งหมด ส่วนนี้จริงๆ ไม่
เกี่ยวกับคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมเลย
นี่คือวิธีหา
ตัวประกอบที่ไม่ธรรมดาของจำนวนเต็มบวก N ที่ให้มา
และยังไงก็ตาม วิธีนี้ใช้ได้เฉพาะเมื่อ N เป็นจำนวนคี่ และไม่ใช่จำนวน
เฉพาะยกกำลัง
สองกรณีนั้น เมื่อ N
เป็นจำนวนคู่หรือกำลังของจำนวนเฉพาะ สามารถจัดการแยกต่างหากได้
มีวิธีคลาสสิกที่มีประสิทธิภาพสำหรับทั้งการตรวจจับและ
จัดการสองกรณีนั้น
วิธีนี้เป็นแบบน่าจะเป็น มันอาจล้มเหลว แต่
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะล้มเหลวจะไม่เกินครึ่ง
และเราสามารถรันมัน
หลายครั้งอย่างอิสระเพื่อลด
ความน่าจะเป็นของข้อผิดพลาดลงอย่างรวดเร็วแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล
อย่างแรก เราเลือก A ระหว่าง
สองถึง N ลบหนึ่ง แบบสุ่มสม่ำเสมอ
จากนั้นเราคำนวณ GCD ของ A กับ N
และถ้า GCD มากกว่า
หนึ่ง เราก็โชคดีมาก
GCD จะเป็นตัวประกอบของ N และเราก็แค่แสดงผลแล้วหยุด
ไม่งั้น อัลกอริทึมดำเนินต่อ และตอนนี้เรารู้ว่า A อยู่ใน ZN star
และตอนนี้เราคำนวณอันดับของ A ซึ่งเป็นจุดที่เราต้องการคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
หรือบางทีเรามีวิธีอื่น
ในการคำนวณอันดับ อัลกอริทึมไม่ได้
สนใจว่ามาจากไหน แต่วิธีเดียว
ที่เรารู้จักที่จะทำอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
คือด้วยคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
ถ้าอันดับ R เป็นจำนวนคู่ เราจะคำนวณ GCD ของ
A ยกกำลัง R หารสอง ลบหนึ่ง กับ N
และถ้า GCD นั้นมากกว่าหนึ่ง เราก็มีตัวประกอบของ N อีกครั้ง ดังนั้นเราแสดงผลแล้วหยุด
ไม่งั้นอัลกอริทึมล้มเหลว และในกรณีนั้น เราสามารถ
กลับไปเริ่มใหม่แล้วเลือก A ตัวอื่น
และหวังว่าจะได้ผลลัพธ์
ที่ดีกว่าในครั้งต่อไป
แค่นั้นเอง และยังไงก็ตาม เมื่อ
เราหาตัวประกอบของ N ได้แล้ว เราสามารถวนซ้ำทั้งตัวประกอบนั้น
และหารด้วยตัวประกอบนั้น จนกว่าเราจะได้การแยกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของ N
แล้วทำไมมันถึงใช้ได้?
มีสองประเด็นหลัก ข้อแรกคือเพราะ A ยกกำลัง R เท่ากับหนึ่ง modular N
เราได้ว่า N หาร A
ยกกำลัง R ลบหนึ่ง ลงตัว
สองข้อความนั้น
จริงๆ แล้วเทียบเท่ากัน นี่คือนิยามของ mod N ที่จะพบในหนังสือทฤษฎีจำนวน
ข้อสอง ถ้า R เป็นจำนวนคู่ สมการที่
เรามีตรงนี้เป็นจริง
นี่คือสูตรที่รู้จักกันดี
สำหรับผลต่างของกำลังสอง
จริงๆ แล้วสมการเป็นจริงสำหรับทุก R แต่เราต้องการให้ R หารสอง
เป็นจำนวนเต็มในขั้นตอนที่สี่
และถ้าเรารวมสองข้อเท็จจริงเข้าด้วยกัน เราจะเห็นว่าทุกตัวประกอบเฉพาะของ N ต้องหาร
นิพจน์ในวงเล็บตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง
เพราะนั่นเป็นวิธีเดียว
ที่ N จะหารผลคูณนั้นลงตัว
อาจเป็นไปได้ว่าทุก
ตัวประกอบเฉพาะของ N หารนิพจน์
แรกในวงเล็บและไม่หารตัวที่สอง แต่สำหรับ A ที่เราสุ่มมา
มันไม่ค่อยเป็นไปได้ และดังนั้นเมื่อเราคำนวณ
GCD ในขั้นตอนที่สี่ เรามักจะได้ผลคูณ
ของตัวประกอบเฉพาะ
บางส่วนของ N แต่ไม่ใช่ทั้งหมด
การวิเคราะห์เรื่องนี้อย่างรอบคอบ
ต้องใช้ทฤษฎีจำนวนบ้าง แต่มันเป็นทฤษฎีจำนวนพื้นฐาน
ดังนั้นถ้าเราพบว่า
ทฤษฎีจำนวนน่าสนใจ และต้องการเรียนรู้เพิ่มเติม ลองทำการวิเคราะห์นี้ดู
การทำเรื่องแบบนี้เป็นวิธีที่ดีเยี่ยมในการเรียนรู้เพิ่มเติม แต่ผมจะปล่อยให้เป็นหน้าที่ของเรา
และนั่นคือจุดจบของบทเรียน ในบทเรียนนี้ เราครอบคลุม
ปัญหา phase estimation วิธีแก้มันอย่างมีประสิทธิภาพ
บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัม
และวิธีนำคำตอบไปใช้เพื่อได้อัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ที่มีต้นทุนพหุนามสำหรับการแยกตัวประกอบจำนวนเต็ม
หวังว่าจะได้พบกันในบทเรียนถัดไป ซึ่งเป็นเรื่อง
อัลกอริทึมค้นหาควอนตัมของ Grover
ลาก่อนจนกว่าจะถึงตอนนั้น